[inaudible] are recording to server the fuck outta here.
Server.
We're playing music that no one's heard.
This shit is
Diane.
D aunt word
original Max could climb a big fan of that shit.
Take this baby to maximum
cash but feel
free to get back down.
Well,
uh,
just say that,
that,
that's a fucking South African band.
It's Deann or now,
but they were a bunch of different things before they were Deann word.
And uh,
I've been obsessed with them for the last couple of weeks.
Man.
They're fucking awesome every now and then,
yet you catch a band.
That's the shit.
Uh,
speaking to the shed,
Freddie Lockhart,
ladies and gentlemen,
old school comedy road dog,
my friend from many,
many,
many moons ago through that,
back when Freddie was actually working at the comedy store,
Freddie started out the right way.
Like,
uh,
like so many comedy store warriors have done work in there,
you know,
either doing the door or you know,
work in,
uh,
work in the cover booth.
And you know,
there's,
that's one of the cool things about the comedy store is that almost everybody
working there is,
wants to be a comic.
Almost everybody working there wants to,
uh,
wants to make it in show business.
There's a lot of people that are great people that work in other clubs,
but they're not,
they're not there because they want to be comedians.
The comedy store is entirely comprised as people who want to be committed.
And the accountants,
everybody.
Yeah.
Everybody.
It's ridiculous,
unfortunately,
except for the fucking managers.
And that's why the place sucks.
A bag of dicks.
Oh,
one of the all time classic comedy clubs,
but a CBGBS if you're up to calm,
it's now run by Mitzi shore anymore,
unfortunately.
No.
Um,
but,
uh,
it's still a great fucking place.
And that's where I met Freddy Lockhart Bay back in the design flashlight.
Flashlight is our sponsor.
We have to,
uh,
let everybody know about that.
You could go to Joe rogan.net and buy it.
And if you a,
you click the link and enter in the code name Rogan,
you get 15% off.
That's what it is.
Right?
Show.
Show him the flashlight.
This is the alien one.
It's blue.
It's got two clips.
Nice.
Put your finger in it.
A star Trek.
Nobody's fuck this.
I wouldn't do that except me.
I've always wondered.
I was like,
what is it going to feel like?
That's,
that's pretty good.
What do you think?
It's really interesting feeling,
right?
It definitely feels better than,
well,
probably my rough hands.
You just warm that up on it and I was scratching,
just warm it up a little and I'll be in Austin,
Texas this weekend,
all weekend,
Thursday,
Friday and Saturday at Cap City comedy club.
And uh,
Joey Coco Diaz will be with me.
It's a rare treat that we get to bring Joey
on the road.
I think about Joey is Joey.
He's the best.
He's my favorite comedian of all time,
but he's as about as reliable as fucking a fake Rolex.
It had just like,
you just can't count on them.
I used to,
I started taking people with me.
I only used to bring one opener for the longest time.
Right.
But Joey flaked so many times that I started taking a second opener with me just
so that I could still book Joe.
Yeah.
And under.
So if the shit hit the fan and only hit the family one out of every 20 times,
but it hit the fan every now and then you'd be in Jersey going,
where the fuck are you?
I'm not going to lie to your dog.
I never left Vegas.
The excuses always admirable and and and in an entertaining at best to get an
excuse,
she might just not get phone calls back.
Yeah,
for like months.
Black Dog.
And then once you do talk to them,
it never gets brought up.
What up dog?
What are we doing?
What's up Qca clicker.
I don't want to go back to those days of my life.
So he's going,
we had a scare today.
I thought that thought it wasn't going to go.
You never know Joey,
anything could happen.
He's always got this,
I got something going on in dogs.
That Disney channel movie.
I think it's going to be big.
I get to show my balls,
they're going to blow it out.
Have you seen the previews of his a Disney movie?
No,
laser called.
It's called like the dog that saved Christmas and they released like they're
releasing like a whole bunch of them in the first one Joey was like 400 pounds
or whatever.
Oh yeah.
And then he lost a lot of ways and sent out.
They were like really concerned.
But anyways,
I just saw the preview I,
but it's,
I think it's just about to come on DVD.
I saw the preview and Joey Diaz has a little scene in there where he's in drag
and it's the cutest thing ever.
See what the fuck would they care if you lose a hundred pounds?
He looks better.
He's hitting it looks like he's healthy right into the goddamn.
That's what they ended up doing.
They wrote in the whole weight watcher thing.
Is he keeping it off?
He's still keeping the way.
What does he does weight watchers?
He falls for him.
I got points,
cock sucker and he'll explain it to you with anger in his voice.
Oh,
that's great.
Good for him.
Yeah.
He's like a fucking slice of pizza and a coke.
That's eight points.
You can't take eight point cock sucker.
You deserve to be fat.
They'll get fucking angry.
He like gets very passionate about his weight watchers,
but yet when I go out to eat,
he'll be like,
fuck,
this is only for weight watcher points.
I'm like,
dude,
that's not shows with salmon,
salmon,
snickers.
How many points is that?
Oh,
it's like,
you know,
80 point like your home.
Is that supposed to be your whole day?
So what did he lose?
He lost a hundred pounds on your fucking pants.
Pretty fucking.
Yeah,
he put it together.
Especially not doing the lap band or the Castro.
He will old school way.
He got really upset about that too.
You know,
we would talk about it.
He goes,
I'm not going to do it.
Talk.
He got like real passionate about,
he goes by [inaudible].
He's had that fucking thing.
He blew it out twice.
So surgeries,
I'm not going to get cut open bro.
I'm going to get fucking cuddle.
Right.
You just,
he manned up and up and he fucking lost the weight.
It's incredible.
Well,
the thing with those things too,
it's like your,
your brain doesn't catch up with what has happened to your body.
You know what I mean?
It's like that's part of the whole working it process,
you
know?
Yeah.
You can't just fucking rewire your body and then your brain is still jack.
This need constant need for food.
You didn't pick time.
It's an obsession,
man.
The people become so,
it's so easy for people to get obsessed with things.
For me,
I can get obsessed with cute tips,
putting q-tips in my ears.
I can get obsessed with video games.
I get obsessed with beating off.
I can get obsessed with things where they're like just like consume me.
Like I have to do though.
What the fuck?
Kind of a flaw is that share what a goofy ass flaw.
It's sucks to.
It's,
we all have I,
it's not the food one.
Right,
exactly.
It's like mine was always like the weed one,
you know,
the sleeping one.
It could be bad things,
but I just at least smart enough to say,
you know,
to not deny the addiction.
Just to know.
It could get out of hand if I gave into it.
You gotta be careful,
you know,
respect the beast in there.
You know you gotta be very careful.
It's like due to use to smoke cigarettes,
I'm just going to have one cigarette
in a wrestling match right here with the devil.
He's going to tie you up bitch.
Yeah.
You're,
you're,
you're screwed with that.
You fucked up.
I just,
I just complete out and out say a for it.
It's like the video games,
the grand theft auto.
I got so addicted to it like my life was,
I was literally dreaming and thinking and grant and my mindset would be like,
oh just take that cop's car and Jack and then we'll get to,
we'll get to the gig quicker.
Like I'm like real life.
That's my subconscious mind.
But luckily in my conscious mind is like no,
you,
you know there's eight that rewires kids and mixing it with him.
I used to play this game where you jumped from building to building.
I forget which game at [inaudible] city of heroes and after I played it for like
a month straight for like 10 hours a day,
I would go outside and forget,
I can't jump on top of buildings like I was just driving going,
I can jump on that building and that building.
I'm like,
what am I thinking?
And it's very Darwinian.
If you're a kid now,
if you're a kid,
you haven't laid down those those at least those deep rooted thoughts and will
tell you that you know you can't do that.
That little voice that says no,
don't kill him.
It's like you don't have physical limitation.
The law doesn't even hold you accountable until you're eight years old for
murder or something like that.
So think about that.
If you're playing those video games and your four or five,
that's all you know.
You don't think he just pulled the trigger.
Especially boys,
you,
when you have little girls,
you see them around a little boys.
You realize how fucking crazy boys are from the get go.
Like VR.
There are a lot of the things that are fucked up about human beings because of
our culture,
but there's a lot of shit that's just in there,
man.
When you see like little boys and this little boy,
there was two little two year old babies in this,
this big inflatable play thing and won like seven,
eight year old boy.
Okay.
And a seven,
eight year old boy was fucking throwing himself through the air and crashing
into the walls.
This thing with no regard to these babies that were around them.
It was such a trip to watch and I was watching him like,
dude,
you got to settle down.
You got to sell down and you're looking at them like he can't even help himself.
This kid is wired up with his fucking chimpanzee DNA.
I mean,
he's like six man.
He's just throwing himself into the cage of this thing.
They are there in grand that where they're crazy to get that shit out.
It's inside of them.
If you take a kid like that and don't exercise that it should be a crime.
It should be a crime to have a little male monster and not work it out.
Yeah,
you gotta you gotta treat him just like a dog.
Give him a ball and make them go chase it to,
when I first started doing wrestling in high school,
I first started like really working out a real cause.
Like I used to,
I did martial arts before that,
but quite honestly the,
the karate class than I did before wrestling.
It wasn't good.
It wasn't like it wasn't hard enough to really break.
You are wrestling practice would break,
break,
make you question yourself and,
but you get out of there though and you're so peaceful.
Oh yeah.
Like there's nothing left.
Absolutely.
You don't,
you don't need to get upset about some asshole who cuts in front of you.
The red light,
it's all like whatever.
I would see those guys in high school.
I played football and it was,
the thing is it was only hard for two weeks.
Hell Week.
The beginning of summer,
especially in Arizona,
it's hot as hell,
but the higher you went up and Varsity,
it was so easy because they didn't want anybody to get hurt.
Nobody was going into freshman football.
You had to hit the biggest gun.
They didn't care.
They just size to anybody against anybody,
but it would watch the wrestlers go back to the locker room.
After we went back to the locker room,
I was like,
those guys just,
I mean,
they were just,
they would just lay there,
there'd be drenched Brodo,
but they,
you never saw them on campus during the meat head crap that we were doing.
The football players,
they were exhausted.
They're exhausted and they do get humbled to and they knew that they could,
they could end this situation a lot quicker than we could,
you know of.
There's also,
they get it out of their system.
Yeah.
If you're always competing with men and you're always like throwing yourself in
there,
you don't want to do anything and it's like you're doing it and it's the safest
way to do it and deal with your biology,
what you're doing as you're doing it in a controlled environment with a bunch of
other people who agree to it and it's honorable and you do it like you tap each
other out and there's not even any hard feelings.
Right.
It's like,
well you're like,
when you do Jujitsu,
there's no hard feelings when God's get got,
you know,
somebody taps you out,
you go,
that's what happens.
You get caught.
What did I do wrong?
Did I put my arm through?
Oh,
I fucked up.
I forgot to put the arm here.
I thank you.
Thank you.
And you go back again.
It's like,
but you get all this ingrained male dominator shit out of your system that's
opposed to live all like hanging out like this.
Oh yeah.
Chimps,
you know like you,
you know,
chimps don't like hang out that much ripped off other chimps.
Like if they go meet other champs,
like they have like little tribes.
I saw me to their ships.
They're fighting.
They're,
yeah,
they're fucking fighting big for sure.
That did the death.
Sometimes they creep over and they don't even know these champs is Jakob.
They just decide who's in the team and that's it.
But we've got to deal with so many people all day long.
You can't just jack people,
but those signals are still present in like ghostly form in your brain.
That's why.
That's why my dick on youtube videos,
I will lay.
What do you mean?
I'm just kidding.
I'm not a dick.
I know it's true.
It's like message boards watching people around message boards and psychosis and
I'm,
I'm always like,
all right,
if we are talking about something in a room together,
all in a group and you're the person saying they're like this person's fat.
Oh God,
this person sucks.
That's so stupid.
I'm like,
are you gonna be sitting there going,
yeah,
listen to that guy.
No,
you're going to be doing the same thing you do on a message board where it's
just like,
what's wrong with this?
Psycho crazy.
Since we had a social face that we put on for social issues,
but at home,
that's maybe who you really are.
The you're saying on youtube fall been out with someone who's barely keeping it
together.
Just like,
yeah.
Nice jets,
great shirt.
Like,
wow,
why don't you just shut up my shirt?
You know,
they just boiling under the skin around,
did you match this unsolicited?
They do the thing where they,
they take a left turn when they see your reaction,
like what the fuck?
And they're like,
oh no,
no,
no.
Yeah,
yeah,
I'm kidding.
It just like,
I'm not that mean.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of dudes who just like to get douchey with dudes.
They just didn't want to get out of the fucking system.
Dare you Brian.
It's funny,
the other day I called Freddy and he called me back and said,
sorry,
I just woke up and I looked at the clock.
I was like,
oh,
it's two 30
they had already ended.
It's the real shit.
He's rocking it,
man.
He's a fucking comic.
Well,
he's an artist.
Chow Tommy.
Let me hear it.
It's not just that.
Okay.
Have you been talking to Mitzi?
Wow.
Mitsui and I did talk and you can work out in the belly room,
Joe Chi.
But that's it for right now.
Wow.
What an honor.
How often you rubber feet.
Wow.
It's not just,
okay because Richard Pryor.
Yes.
Robert [inaudible].
Freddy Lockhart,
by the way,
used to be on the Frank Kelly endo shown is,
in my opinion,
one of the best impression of south.
There you,
you do impressions that are very weird,
man.
You do some impressions that uh,
no one else does.
That's,
I figured that that's what you should do.
I always figured it's like,
why get in and do something.
The Nicholson,
the ones like that,
it's like,
I try to find a strange one and I do it like I see,
man,
don't nobody do ice tea punch of pitches.
I do it better than I to t man.
Not Too with voiceover work and what not.
I love to say what not.
Do you know the Lisbon,
everything.
I try to make a little list there and he fights a little lift,
but it's kind of gangster and it works for him.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause it's dig it.
I used to do that at the comedy store.
I used to call the comedy stories ice tea and this poor guy,
Kenny Tenney,
this guy used to work the phones there.
Do you remember this guy?
He was Mitsis Pool Guy and there was something,
something was off with him.
Definitely say,
I mean,
I don't want to say what he had,
but he definitely wasn't one of,
you know,
he wasn't thinking right but he was,
he was like,
he got uh,
he made money.
He,
he had a pool company,
he cleaned pulls and he did it well,
but he'd function like an eight year old and a,
I would call him every time he would pick up the phone,
I would call them and it would be ice tea and he would fall for it every time.
But like,
Yo man,
I'm bringing 30 people in tonight,
man.
What you got on my booth that you would
like?
I miss you too.
We don't have a booth at six 30 I'm like,
you better build one for me.
Well,
I'll see if we can,
I'm just like,
ah.
That's how it would brush up on the impression as if I could full Kenny Tenney.
I felt like it was golden.
Oh yeah.
How do you,
do you work in presidency?
You practice them at home and then eventually bring on this stage or do you know
when you hear somebody whether or not you can do it?
You know,
I,
there's a lot of people,
if you hear them right away,
I know I could do,
if somebody had,
it tends to have a deeper voice or something like that or if there's a weird
thing about them,
I know I can do it,
but I always more so than the way it sounds,
it's the way somebody looks when they talk because people move their mouth a
certain way.
That will reveal happy breath.
Notice you did that with the Obama thing,
that Obama thing.
I watched it online where they took some footage from like the 70s it looks like
and inserted your clips.
Right.
That was great stuff,
man.
Yeah.
Really do a good Obama.
It was a,
that was a show in Super Lux said Internet series I had,
but the whole thing was,
uh,
I,
I would take facts and skew them a little.
I love time.
Traveling is my biggest obsession,
so that's fine.
Yeah,
I'm obsessed with it.
I'm working on a show right now about time travel.
And you're talking to the right guy.
I'm talking tacky on particles,
the whole thing.
I'm into it,
man.
Who?
Ronald Maladies?
Do you know the whole story?
No,
no,
no.
Fuck.
Is he a traveler?
I love time travel to Ronald Malate is the premier expert in America on Tom
Travel.
And this is the crazy part about,
and we've talked to him on the essay about him on the show before,
but I'm gonna,
I'm gonna bring it up again just cause it's such a fascinating story.
The dude's like a fucking Spiderman comic book.
Okay.
His Dad died when he was a child,
so he became obsessed.
He loved his dad and became upstairs and read about him.
I know exactly what he's like to see a black guy.
He has a black black.
Okay.
Yeah sure.
And he developed and isn't it funny that we have to say he's a black guy?
But that's why I was like,
cause I was excited about it all.
He was black,
super powerful.
You know?
Uh,
like Neil degrasse Tyson.
Yeah.
Those kind of guys.
He's only a few of this son died.
You know his father,
Father Guy.
Here's his story.
His father die.
Brian,
how dare you.
Was he robbing a place so white to the way you say it?
You just smelly cheese,
convenience store.
They were,
they were in the baseball together.
Him and his old man,
they left the club cards and stuff.
So his whole life became obsessed with time travel.
Cause you want to go back in time and save his dad,
right?
Oh it's fucking trippy shit.
What did,
the guy has a peer reviewed paper that he wrote on time travel with.
They were physicists agree like theoretically this all makes sense.
If you can develop this kind of power,
you could go back in time.
Right now we can't develop the kind of power that's necessary to do it,
but,
right.
But that's trippy shit.
I think he didn't,
he isn't he currently building a light thing that he's trying to send the light?
Yeah.
Light literally back in time.
And it makes sense what he's saying.
And I was,
I actually,
when I spoke on that,
I was excited because I thought,
you know,
time travel.
I always thought it'd be possible.
My mom worked at NASA when I was a little kid and that,
I think that's where the curiosity started when I lived at Edwards Air Force
Base,
they were always texting like testing ex jets and crazy shit that the government
was working on,
which just made me knew that they're really aware of shit that we had no idea
about.
And that's when I kind of got an a timetable and I thought,
you know,
you could future time travel,
just manipulation of time.
Basically you stay above the earth's atmosphere at a mile or go gazillion miles
an hour.
You'll come back and you'll have lost time.
You know,
you'll be here,
you'll be ahead,
you'll be still 30 but everyone will be a hundred years old.
Right.
So I was doing that,
but I got really excited when I read his article that you could go back in the
past like wait a second,
you can,
you can do that.
You know you can take,
it could only go back to the moment.
The first time machine machine was invented.
That's just the,
I had this argument with Brian and Christie about this and the whole thing about
time travel.
It's like doesn't time.
Once it's exposed,
isn't it all a moot point after that?
You know what I mean?
But that's what they talk about.
What the grandfather clause.
If you go back and you shoot your grandfather,
then that makes it impossible for you to time travel.
But that doesn't,
because I think that just means you break time.
They did not,
didn't take that operate in day.
That option under consideration.
When people talk about that story,
the grandfather paradox,
they always say,
well,
if you did go back in time,
he'd kill your grandfather before your father was ever born for you would never
exist to make the time machine,
but that doesn't mean you couldn't do that.
Right?
You could still do that.
People say,
well that means you couldn't have a time machine.
We,
yeah,
you could.
Yeah,
You would just do that and then you break everything like a parallel life,
like kind of like back to the [inaudible] to 1955 who want to become string
theory.
It goes off into another world that believe,
and this is a a very strange theory,
but it might be just as real as the one we live in,
that they believe that every second you live your life,
every,
every decision you make,
everything you do,
all the energy that he puts out,
guides you into various parallel dimensions.
And now we are not just living in one dimension that we are living in in an
infinite number of dimensions that are all around us all the time.
And we can choose to slide through these dimensions with our thoughts.
Oh Wow.
Is it as you live your life,
as you live your life correctly,
as you live your life in the direction that you want to do with little
procrastination focused and love and joy as you do this correctly,
you move through higher and higher dimension.
Well that's a,
they all exist all around too much with Buddhism teaches two and then the whole
pot.
And even with the,
like the,
the Yogis,
they know about that and,
and you know,
through meditation and plan travel,
they know about that.
I mean you can't say they know.
They can't say.
It's an idea that western science has come along and started to pick a path and
ask why.
You know in the line the things in the brain that that make it possible.
Did you guys see the thing on CNN last week,
but the alleged time traveler lady with the silicone.
That's nonsense.
There are crazy people.
People aren't even paying attention.
They,
they asked.
They had hearing aids back then.
Right?
Exactly right.
Yeah.
What's crazy is that video became big and then the next day all the places were
like,
no,
it's just a hearing aid,
but yet I still get emails everyday from people,
Twitter messages all day.
It's time to drove a real,
yeah,
there's cell phone towers in 1910 how is this fucking phone works?
Who's this punk calling with this bitch calling the future?
She's calling from the past to the future because otherwise it's not a fucking
phone for her to be calling more realistic.
If she was just like staring,
editors are impressed by someone holding their ear up to their day.
Well,
the,
yeah,
that one was just a,
they wanted to throw it out there and they knew that they couldn't back it up.
Like CNN ran it and it was like
running that.
It was
the front page.
So that's so stupid and distracting and you know,
I,
as much as I love time travel is like,
come on,
don't make a mockery of time travel by,
by showing crap like that.
That's what really sucks.
Think about if you could even times help,
you could go to the 80s and whip out your iPhone.
You'd get arrested for witchcraft or I mean they would stomp you to death that
they saw that the boys have done.
If you go 10 years ago,
that would happen too.
You know what I mean?
It's like the way technology,
I think in our lifetime,
like this kid's not gay.
It's true.
It's like the kids today,
we're closer to kids who grew up in like the 1940s we're close to the cave men.
Exactly the way things have changed.
I'm watching kids today growing up with porn from the get go.
These kids are like 13 they're taken in the ass.
I think that would be supposed to do,
you know
it's the chickens have come home to roost.
All those shitty parents out there that make porn stars.
All those shitty parents have infected other people's kids as well to porn porn
on their playstation,
taking pictures that pussies and chance sending them throughout class.
People are,
kids are filthy today.
Dirty little fucks.
I was cleaning my laptop out last night going through all this shit just trying
to make room for it cause it's just crazy crowded and I'm just going through all
these videos and I found out that like if you have the mail app and you have
like a Gmail account on there,
it will download everything from your Gmail account.
Every video,
every photo.
At least that's the setting I had.
And so it was like where's all my hard drive space?
So I'm going through all this shit.
And there was videos that people had sent me that message.
It went to spam folders,
you know,
like crazy videos and like,
just spam videos and stuff.
One of them was this woman where they're taking that.
You've all seen this where the the funnel with the putting the eels and the
woman and then it starts shooting out like salmon.
I'm showing my,
this girl I just met,
I'm like doing this and she looks over.
She goes,
what the fuck are you looking at?
I don't know,
but that's just crazy to think like somebody sent me that video.
If I ever lose my laptop and like the FBI goes,
hey,
let's go see what's in this laptop.
Oh,
he has videos of young girl with salmon is coming out of their ass.
Oh my God.
No.
Was when the girl,
no,
I'm not saying salmon's are big.
I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying what I was going to say,
that stream.
But that video exists on my laptop and that would be knowing is what I'm talking
about.
You know,
it could be anything.
It could be child porn,
it could be any.
That's what I'm saying.
But that was kind of scary.
So fuck the mail APP.
Well that's the thing too.
It's like,
it's like that the sensitized think if you're in in third grade and you see that
like you know around fifth grade we,
we'd get a,
Debbie does Dallas tape.
Somebody's dad would have it,
somebody would have the balls to gang kit while his old man was drunk and they
would pass around eighth grade.
You know like everybody got to see it and you put it back and you gave it back
to the kid.
But that was,
that was pretty much born then.
And it's like now.
Yeah,
they can look at it on their cell phone.
In class I iPhones.
Yeah.
I phones get the html five is like the standard for porn sites now because,
because the iPhone is don't use flat.
So all these points,
I just switched into html five and you can watch a show on your iPhone.
What would a gangster that was on Steve jobs
part too is gags and he goes,
he goes,
you know what?
I won't put flat plastic needs to catch up with me.
I mean,
that was just like,
that was just like [inaudible] 85% of the animated websites on the Internet use
it.
He's like,
no man,
no.
Back in the day when you liked a girl,
you would like,
Hey,
meet me at the big toy and I'll finger you or touch your boobs are stuff.
Nowadays they're just like,
hey,
go to the bathroom and finger your pussy and I'm going to go into the bathroom
and finger my Dick and then we're going to facetime it.
We're going to facetime it on the third grade.
Why Fi network?
You know?
Can you imagine what these kids are doing nowadays with like facetime and kids
and stuff?
It should also,
it should also honestly make for some really smart fucking kid.
So if they,
if they use the knowledge,
there's going to be some smart fucking kid,
it'll be so much more aware of it.
Yeah,
they're going to be much,
much more advanced.
So it one thing at that age,
I didn't know a damn thing and I was 18 I was,
I had,
I get very uncomfortable around people who were religious because I thought
maybe they knew something.
I thought maybe they were in on something and they were like,
they were like more powerful.
Oh Wow.
I believed it.
I thought when I was 18 that's a fucking dumb.
I like,
I wasn't,
I was religious when I was younger and then when I was 18,
I was like,
because when you're young,
you're fucking dumb man.
Oh yeah.
No access to information.
There's no fucking Internet.
When I was a kid,
I had the people in my neighborhood and school.
Yeah.
Is that shit anywhere grounded inside your brain though?
Like it,
does it ever come out where you're sitting there like,
like I could after earthquake and were like,
Jesus,
you bring out your rosary and stuff and you said no,
no,
not at all.
No.
It's gone pretty big time.
Where you,
what you Catholic?
I was raised Catholic when I was in first grade.
And then,
uh,
I immediately thought it was horseshit because first grade was so horrible,
this fucking cunt,
none that I had sister Mary Josephine,
this fucking crazy bitch.
She was just incarnate evil,
an evil dried up old woman who wasted her life on some nonsense and fucking
hated kids who were just super religious growing up.
No,
not at all.
And um,
my parents were an interracial couple.
It's like already then don't do a lot of cocaine and my parents.
So what happened with me is I went from this religious upbringing from,
you know,
Catholic school in first grade to moving to San Francisco in second grade with
my mother's new husband who was a hippie.
Oh Wow.
Computer programmer with long hair.
So my dad was just like Cop Douche bag in jersey,
you know,
and I grew up like in that like Catholic,
hey,
you're not in the Lord's name in vain book,
son of a bitch,
slap you.
That kind of,
I grew up in that.
Like people would just smack in the head for no reason.
Wow.
I grew up in that and then all of a sudden hippies in San Francisco.
It was a total trip.
My next door neighbors were these gay dudes.
He used to get naked and hang out with my aunt because my aunt,
you know,
didn't worry about them fucking her,
because they were gay as fuck.
Big Muscular Black Guy,
dark black Africa,
Kenya,
black.
It's fuck you just be naked.
One lobes and his boyfriend and the ball,
both of them were just,
then they all get together and just smoke weed and take their clothes off.
Wow.
Nobody fucked.
Nobody did anything.
They just lie around smoking weed and I about this when I was seven.
Wow.
You know,
so I went from this fucking crazy primate jungle of Jersey.
Italians
can each other and throwing shit at each other.
It's just like being in a chimp cage.
Right.
So I went from that to hippies and gay dudes were a naked smoking weed.
Hanging out with my aunt does is hilarious.
This is the craziest fucking won 80 ever.
And you've got good parts of both though.
When you say like good parts of like,
you know the,
the progressive thoughts and,
and ideas,
but also the,
you know,
you're,
you're not your typical pussy comic.
I'll tell you that much coast thing is where men are forced to become men.
Sure.
At a quick age you get fucked with good,
you look in to kick your ass.
You know,
the line of the west coast people,
it's a little more relaxed in that.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's good that it's more relaxed in that,
but I think it creates people that are a little more confused.
Yeah.
There does seem to be a,
a survival of the fittest element in Jersey,
New York area.
Like a lot of the kids who want a smart people there,
two men talk to some stressed out smart motherfuckers in New York.
Oh yeah.
They're intense,
man.
They're fucking stressed out.
I'll step outside for a cigarette.
You don't even know what's going on with Lehman Marcus.
And if I go the whole way,
the system is set up,
it's impossible for them to fail.
What they're doing is they're getting fucking paint the blah,
blah,
blah.
These are smart,
super intense motherfuckers.
It's like,
I have to choose what I do here because I can go with you on this crusade.
Right?
Yeah,
exactly.
I lose my life to this crazy type of thinking or I can go,
yeah,
I'm going to go to California.
Yeah.
And I'm going to smoke some pot and relaxed.
It's definitely is if there is an intensity on the east coast,
I mean there's definitely a reason that all the Ivy League schools are on the
east coast.
It's like there's an intensity there and there's a,
there's a,
there's a fervor about things.
Part of it has to do with dealing with weather.
Weather is a humbling thing and I think it makes you,
you know,
you have to stockpile food for the winter.
Sure.
You didn't just have to do it in 1950 you how to do it in 1850 when there's no
refrigerator.
Okay.
And a lot of those people that live there are the ancestors for people that
lived.
I mean,
those are the people that are established it and the other people,
if it wasn't for,
if they weren't there 200 years ago,
they were in another country.
Okay.
And they took a chance coming over on a fucking boat,
some place they've never seen when there was no movies about it,
no Internet.
They had in your stories from someone,
a letter,
you know,
Dear John,
I have made it here to new land.
Oh,
the fruit is plenty.
A Brown people are strange.
They have paint on their face.
Gold is everywhere.
Come soon,
right?
So they took chances and fucking gun boats and traveled across a goddamn ocean
when there's no gps,
no cell phones to fucking flares pitch.
If that fucking poke goes down,
you're done.
That's it.
You're in the middle of the ocean,
which is bigger than the continent on a gamble for a maybe dam.
And you're just hoping to float it out.
Crazy ass.
That's how bad Europe sucked.
Your sucks so bad in the 17 hundreds dudes are willing to get dysentery.
All a raw.
And what would they get scurvy from?
No.
Vitamin C,
they were fucking eating rats,
bro,
to stay alive.
People were dying.
They were throwing them off the boat.
A lot of people die.
They would get sick,
everyone would get ill,
the plague,
all that.
That's why they come here.
They'd rather come here to nothing,
to having an established roads and shit.
We had nothing.
And then we built our own,
we our own.
Yeah.
They became to trees and water and they're like,
I'll take it will take me the fuck away from these Douche bags over there.
Yeah,
exactly.
And they kept the attitude too,
especially on the east coast where they call on us.
They just kept the attitude.
And I think it seems to me that the west coast is all slowly as far,
far as you get out,
a big percentage of those people are going to be the children of the people who
originally landed.
Oh right.
They're going to be the people that got there.
Everybody landed on the east branch.
Right,
right.
And so then they go,
oh fuck this place.
Let's keep moving west.
And they kept going and going and going and going.
So the people that made it all the way here,
it's almost like spoiled children.
Yeah.
It's almost like they don't appreciate what it takes to make all this happen.
Like you,
you're lucky you're just in a lucky spot.
You found a spot where it doesn't snow and it doesn't get too hot.
Hardly ever rains.
It's an easy spot to live.
It really is.
And they say it does something to the psyche as far as,
you know,
the lack of change kind of almost puts us in a,
in a trance gear up for winter and all that.
Uh,
I do like the idea of socializing.
They're on the east coast.
They are a lot more social with each other and,
and,
and like if you're in New York,
you can see a real heated debate,
get really heated but never come to blows were on the west coast it would come
to blows because it comes to stupid.
We don't comes to.
Exactly.
We don't,
we don't cross paths with each other as much as they do.
We don't share a confined space.
It's real spread out here and always has been.
Well,
it's the,
they walk,
no one walks here.
Oh,
not at all.
There's no walking.
So it's,
it's,
it's a worse,
much worse set up because you're so disconnected from all the people around you.
That's why it's like there's such a big contrast between the haves and haves
nots here.
It's the most obvious,
the most bling bling part of the country.
And one of the reasons why it's because you feel disconnected from other people
that you're around.
You're not touching them,
you're not in contact with them.
You're on the subway with them.
You know,
walking down the street and interacting with them.
And because of that you feel like you're disconnected from them.
You feel like you're not a part of them.
There's something else.
And it makes a separatism between the two,
the two gaps and there's a lack of respect for each other.
And it's like,
that's the thing is you don't hear a,
you know,
the most racist,
homophobic people are,
are places where there aren't any.
Yeah.
Which is so funny because [inaudible] just so it will never understand.
People who hate gay people because it had all the gay people I've ever met.
70% of them were entertaining is fun.
Nicest,
happiest people in the room.
They're like little teddy bears at Dick's and her trying to Jeff the piano guy.
Was he one of the coolest motherfuckers of all times.
So cool.
So creative,
cool,
loyal.
I mean [inaudible] a great guy.
Boy,
why would you care if it had nothing to do with you?
That's stupid.
That's the real prejudice should be against people who are prejudice against gay
people.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Right?
That's like being,
look,
it sounds like a terrible thing to say,
but it's like being upset at someone for any other physical abnormalities.
Being short,
you know,
paying,
being,
be,
having a big fucking nose like Jacqueline hate people that have a big nose.
He,
he's born gay.
I don't think someone's born gay kids hang out with gay people who choose all
tell you man.
Almost to a man.
They all were like when I was seven I looked at the catalogs and I got hard on
why it's illustrated,
made my Dick Tangle.
They all,
they all tell you that there's,
there's some deep seated fear that they have it within them if they hate them.
I just,
some dudes that can be pushed into it and I think they're very scared,
very scared on the fence.
People,
there's a lot of people there are also wired to do what they're not supposed to
do.
There's a lot of people that are just wired to do shit that's wrong.
I think it has something to do with people that like below top videos,
guys that like below Javi,
I think.
No,
I think some dudes for real,
like some dudes are so dumb that there so like they fight the system no matter
what they're wired to not do what they're supposed to arrive.
Right.
If they're in a situation where they're drunk and they're with a guy,
the situation and not do is not let this guy suck.
You're definitely right.
They might be so crazy and stupid.
Right?
Let's see what this is like.
Oh you want to do this shit and I didn't know is I don't give a fuck bro.
I'll do whatever.
And I know we all have guys in our head that we're thinking of,
but it's just like I go cause probably some of the same guys too.
Especially within this,
this thing.
When you meet guys like that,
I've met so many one we were talking about earlier in your kitchen.
Yeah,
there's a lot of them out there.
This is all,
there's a lot of people that are a mess but still man,
the,
the prejudice against hating,
hating gay people to me is one of the most disturbing ones.
It's kitten.
It's getting exposed at it ain't cool though.
I mean it's,
it's definitely there,
but like some really cool people are starting to say knock it off.
You know,
it has to be because I want to be able to use the word faggot and not worry
about anything.
I don't want anybody thinking I'm a Goddamn homophobe.
Yeah,
not at all.
Not even a little bit.
And I want to be able to make fun of crazy people like 10 haggard and not be
called a home hall.
Right.
Or this Eddie long character has been banging kids like yourself out of these
crazy religious assholes that are pretending to be straight.
Right.
Really,
they're gay and they're fucking people.
Yeah.
That doesn't mean as anything.
We're all being gay when I'm talking about some crazy lie or not talking about
two people that are in a consensual relationship and they enjoy it to the
company and they both happened to be,
guys,
what do I give a fuck about that?
What's funny to me is crazy assholes like 10 hag.
Oh yeah.
Who go on a crusade doing math and getting hooked herself.
Craig is looking out,
but it's a funny thing.
Whereas if you start making fun of that guy,
all of a sudden you're,
you're making fun of all games.
Yeah.
That's where it's getting,
it's getting kind of ridiculous.
It's like you still have to be able to like,
you know,
don't make fun of everything.
That's,
if it's valid,
there's hood people and we make fun of them.
It's not like we were making fun of all black people.
Like,
Hey,
remember everybody getting raped in here?
Remember that the Internet put,
is that the one?
Whatever.
Oh yeah.
Getting raped in there.
It's like we were made fun of that person.
Oh,
all black people.
It's just that person.
Same with a flamboyant gay or the guy hiding it.
I mean at the gate,
guys like Haggerty.
That's hilarious.
It's like you find out he's not just gay,
but he's the most devious.
Just disgusting.
Like,
like it's almost like a law and order episode.
It's so bad.
It's like,
are you kidding me?
I loved the gay hooker that he was banging,
went on CNN,
my matches out of him and he's like,
yeah,
I'm a gay hooker.
He just went on CNN.
It admitted he was a gay prostitute and he had sex several times with Ted
Haggard and they smoked meth together and shit.
So brilliant.
I think he probably got more dick after that.
I bet his fucking roster was stock.
Oh,
your day?
No,
the gay hooker gay.
It was like the best thing for his business ever.
If he was smart.
He said,
I'll go on.
Just give me poke my website up there plugging my website.
Yeah,
he got my Bible,
but they it.
Why should I come?
That kind of guy,
like when they,
when they find out about guys like that,
I just slept.
It's like you never think you're going to see that kind of justice in your life
or you want to do it like I know one of the worst part.
Or you're like,
how is this?
For me it's like that's exactly,
it's like a gift from the universe to see rush limbo really get his or somebody
like that.
You know what I mean?
Like to see it somebody who's hooked on Oxycontin,
so it was pretty close.
Homeboy,
he's taken a hundred auctions a day and go ranting on against the liberal elite.
You don't just kick that well,
it made him go deaf.
How about that?
He was doing so many oxies he lost his hearing.
Kahala oh,
that's what it what though?
How the fuck does that word?
I'll let Alex Jones explained the medical,
the reasoning behind the town.
I don't remember it.
Nor do I know if it's correct,
but what he said and it makes sense to me.
I don't think,
look,
you go deaf.
And by the way,
you happen to be doing a hundred docs.
He's a day shift.
Might be related.
I can't believe it.
I can't hear,
but I'm going to continue to use it cause I like,
hi.
Did you can do a rush Limbaugh,
man,
we need to make some parody.
Yes.
Rush Limbaugh,
I buy this off of a liberal,
but I do them.
It's so funny that kind of just tuned into that Dum Dum ideology that just dumb,
dumb.
You know,
I'm the,
I'm a fucking patriot.
Um,
I'm here to do this.
There's a good god,
Christian loving country here and we need to support all these Goddamn,
you know,
hippies out there and liberals.
They're trying to take down this democracy,
this great thing that was founded in 17 [inaudible].
They'll just start rattling off facts.
He believes all that.
You think their APP,
they know the acts,
right?
Roll acts.
They know it's far more complex than that,
but it's,
that position is an excellent profit position.
Yeah.
You can make a lot of fucking money being the Super Patriot guy.
Rallying against the liberals especially is nobody wants to be a pussy and
liberals are pussies.
Yeah.
That's the problem.
That's a big,
you know,
people go,
what do you owe?
Grogan?
Don't tell me you're a liberal.
Come on,
don't tell me I want freedom.
Don't tell me I want the ability to express yourself or hindered.
But I believe in the First Amendment,
I think gay people should be willing to do whatever the fuck they want to do or
allowed to do whatever the fuck they want to do.
People should be able to get married.
You shouldn't have,
you know,
hate crimes shouldn't be real.
I think.
Yeah,
we should figure out how to fucking clean up the ghettos.
They think we should figure out how to use some of our taxes to fucking help out
little kids that are born into some shit position.
And it's supposed to be all within the jurisdiction of this country.
So yeah.
Why aren't we approaching it?
Yeah.
So if that makes me a liberal,
yeah,
I'm a liberal,
which,
which everything you named a lot of people are scared to realize that they are.
I have a lot of friends,
especially back in Arizona growing up there.
Do you know who,
look girl,
I'm from conservative.
It's like,
look at you,
you,
you look like a a rapper right now.
You're not conservative.
You,
you quote Tupac,
you're not conservative.
You're just not what people think of conservative.
A lot of it is in support of big business and that's a problem because they say,
well,
hey,
it's just fuck capitalism.
That's what his country so great.
I totally am in favor of big business.
If it wasn't for them,
we wouldn't have all this cool shit,
but the problem is big business likes to act like it's not a person like it's
above.
Being a person of big business was a person and did all this shit.
It would get sued and closed down and rested and you,
you'd have to,
we don't be an asshole.
The Calbert and Hal Burton theater,
there's $90 billion missing from Iraq.
90 billion.
Hal Burton was a dude and he's like,
I don't know.
It's fucking God man.
They like Bob.
There's 90 billion,
90,000 million.
Where the fuck is it?
I don't know.
Think you could do that.
They would arrest that guy.
They go.
It would be in shackles and in the court there would be the number one story on
the news ever.
Yeah,
Bob Halliburton and then in the court today,
it doesn't know where he put the 98 billion.
It's like misplacing a state.
Like where's my homie?
My homie go a number 90 billion.
That is so huge.
That is such a sizable piece of money that could do so much for every state in
the nation to this.
They would notice it.
I'm talking major shit,
but they're missing so much money over there and they're missing money from the
the mercenary accounts for missing.
Oh,
where the fuck anything is going?
It's amazing.
It Monsanto,
the fucking seed corporation that [inaudible] Genetically Modified Food
Corporation,
the one that sells seeds,
foggy butters,
and then makes the farmer by new seeds next year.
And if you can't use the seat,
yeah,
you can't like reread news them like nature intends.
You can't,
like if you buy a fucking tomato,
tomato has seeds in it.
You know,
and you know,
or you Gregory,
you buy seats with a tomato,
grow the tomato and then take the seeds out of tomatoes.
You grow and replant them.
Della rescue in the law,
you're breaking the law.
They just bought blackwater.
Geez.
They
just been boast.
Evil Corporation bought the second most evil corvette is awful.
I saw that.
I saw with the good to those poor farmers,
those poor guys.
They're like,
what am I supposed to do?
you go and see Joe,
aren't you?
A chick named Kirkland from tap out radio sent me a documentary and I've watched
it and it's,
it's all about these people from these impoverished countries that committed
suicide because they couldn't repay the debt that they owe to Monsanto.
Dude,
it's all about how what they figured out was if you could get patents on plants,
if you could modify a plant and get a patent on it,
then you own it.
Then you copyright that plant's yours.
No one else can grow it.
You can control it.
Just like downloads on the Internet.
That's fucking nuts man.
They figured out a way to do that with food.
I figured out a way to to copyright foods.
When I saw that I saw,
you know,
a bunch of those,
that king cone and all those other ones.
I was honest to God completely naive about the whole thing.
I don't eat fast food right and that kind of crap.
But I was like,
I think I'm doing okay,
but I don't realize it doesn't matter that I'm getting the choice cut of beef at
Ralph's.
It's still from this corn fed,
you know,
slaughtered.
Right.
They said there was something like 14,000 slaughterhouses in America in the
early eighties and now there's like five,
right?
Like literally like it's all going down through one company,
Tyson farms and and a,
I can't remember the other one,
but it's like literally your meat is all and it's like if one's bad,
that's why people are getting sick with a cold.
I like all over it in mass numbers because it's like,
it's not,
nothing's regionalize anymore.
It's all centralized.
It's,
it's like we make it here,
we chopped the meetup,
we put the bad with the good and would sell it to you.
You know,
it's like,
unless you're getting shit from,
you know,
a farmer that,
as a farmer,
your local.
Luckily here we've got 'em farmer's markets,
but it's just,
it's disgusting.
That's fucked up thing about people.
The disconnect between the meat and your food,
the disconnect between where it comes from.
Oh,
here's a,
there's a big disconnect there.
You know,
I've told people that I want to go hunting.
I'm supposed to go hunting with Ricky Schroder this season.
And uh,
Rick shorter loves to hunt.
Really?
Just kind of crazy.
But uh,
um,
but,
and I tell people about that,
like,
why would you want to kill an animal?
Why would you want to do that?
Like,
you eat meat,
don't you eat here?
Someone's killing that.
Well,
you know what?
I don't have to see it if I don't have to see it.
I want to say it.
You don't want to see it,
but you're experiencing what comes from it.
And that's like there's,
there's a disconnect there that can never be healthy,
can never be healthy to be eating animals and not know what it feels like to
kill an animal.
Yeah,
you're right about that.
It can't be because you're not going to appreciate it.
When you think about the people that we consider the most in tune with nature,
those are the American Indians,
right?
Those are the ones that we always glorify and we always,
you know,
saying that these are the guys that were like in tune with the used every part
of the buffalo that they killed.
They didn't waste anything.
They'd lived harmonious,
harmonious harmoniously with her.
They would,
you know,
like praise the spirit of the animal that provided them with food.
You know,
they,
they had this,
this respect for their own prey was like very prevalent throughout their
culture.
You know,
respect for the buffalo and all these different stories about the phone on fall
on slaughter them all.
Ood You mean you want to talk about how destructing human beings can be?
That's one of the greatest stories ever.
Oh yeah.
Just how many they slaughter.
Just slaughtered them.
And how short a time?
There was a millions.
They used to be all over the place.
Buffalo used to be like overwhelming all over this country.
I freak out if I saw one once,
one in my life be crazy.
And they just went just nutty shooting all of them and taken a skins that was
like a big business shooting buffaloes and selling their skins.
Yeah.
And then,
and they didn't know they were picking them off like what?
You know,
just like cherries in the beginning because they didn't know what to be afraid
of man,
because they never had been.
And they never heard a gun,
you know,
they didn't know to scatter when they heard that gun.
They just boom,
one would drop,
boom.
Another withdrawal.
Talk about a fucking species getting jacked species living forever.
And there's one spot having no problems eating grass,
wandering around and all sudden these little pink monkeys with metal bands come
out of nowhere.
Just start dropping motherfuckers.
We talk about an alien invasion man and you're terrifying muscle that she had
been to buffalo.
Oh I know.
That's like an alien invasion.
That's like fucking we are the war or war of world.
We are the world.
We are the road.
All the monkeys are holding hands with the Buffalo.
Think about how fucking freaky that would be a buffalo were intelligent and this
just started happening and they were just stuck with these goofy buffalo bodies.
Dolphine body softens can't really move anything around.
Yeah,
they can't,
they can't manipulate things.
They're kind of stuck just as much as buffalo are.
You just can't say that man doesn't have an effect on us.
An environment.
Cause that's the first series of evidence that that proves that we wiped out
Indians,
buffaloes and everything.
We'd make shit extinct and then we bring a thing or two back like the California
condor again.
But it was like who?
Yeah.
Right.
Keep that spot at home.
That little prick.
Who is my front yard that Al,
I hate that prick.
I hate it.
I hate his guts owl.
That lives in my neighborhood,
bro.
I see this motherfucker at night.
He's a big like a dog.
Eagles are no joke.
They're not ar big and fucking scary and they're like the most ruthless
predators.
Oh,
big time was attack eagles.
They go an eagle's nest.
Why Eagles are sleeping and killed him.
How about that?
Those are those fucking talons.
They get you,
man.
I seen them.
Jack rabbits around here,
man.
It's a trip.
You're like,
you're watching like wild kingdom type shit.
Right?
Right on my street.
It's weird.
I have to have a bird.
There's a bird of prey living in our front yard.
Big One,
and when he gets loud at night,
Ooh,
yeah.
I'm just like,
please be quiet.
It's just so scary.
It's like you hear it coming from his diaphragm.
He sees a man.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like a man.
It's like a 60 pound Anders,
a dude out in the tree.
I mean,
I don't know how much they actually weigh,
but it looks like if it was a dog and be like a wheel and a bed,
they get better.
Take Five,
six foot wingspan flying cat.
There was one outside bigger than cat and the cat,
there was one outside my window the other day.
He was just sitting on my railing.
Mother fucker was,
he had to be almost three feet tall,
loud.
It was playing their,
their,
their pelts gray thing.
But I'm looking,
I'm like that's how a demon thing that only comes out at night and just Jackson
takes advantage of the fact that everyone else is sleeping and just fucks.
Like you got to think like the first person to see.
Like I was thinking that about silverback gorillas compared to the men that they
are discovered pretty recently in the grand scheme of things.
I think the,
the mountain gorilla in the 50s was like the first time somebody came across
like this healthy,
furry black men who can,
I'm half black by the way,
audience,
just to get that out of the way.
Um,
but uh,
like just this monster monster,
there's hundred town ferocious vegetarian and nobody would believe little tiny
ones.
Yeah.
When he's full animals at that too,
you notice them versus the chimps.
Chimps are the ones with those screws.
They start clapping,
you know,
out of control.
They're like gangs,
but the gorilla just eats and all the vegetarians.
That's the difference.
Yeah,
that's clearly a difference.
I mean they,
they figured out a way to supply the body with just plants.
So there's no need to be aggressive except to protect themselves.
Are you,
are you a vegetarian?
No.
Do you know a Herschel Walker?
Yes.
What's his,
his,
his diet real.
It may not be bread and it doesn't make any sense,
but it does it.
How does it make any sense?
You didn't maintain man?
Apparently Hershel Walker is one of those guys and he's a tremendous athlete and
an incredible competitor.
I'm just a great football player and he's been a great spokesperson for,
uh,
depression and for a brain injuries and shit like that.
And he's so fucking,
and he's a bad motherfucker and he's a tremendous athlete and I'm very impressed
with the way he gets to the strike force.
But the knock on him is that he wants people to think and know that he's
extraordinary.
Right.
You know,
so,
I mean,
he is extraordinary.
The athlete.
He's got an extraordinary work ethic,
extraordinary abilities,
but he wants people to think that he's like something out of this world.
So when you say something like,
I don't know,
this is true.
I mean,
this is just what I've heard.
What I've heard is that he'll say,
well,
I only eat a bowl of soup a day.
Meanwhile,
fucking eating food and I look at them,
weighs 220 pounds.
So had disappeared.
That's the thing.
Coffee with your crazy talk,
he's massive.
His trap start from the bottom of his ears and gun necessarily believe has died.
Black.
I'm a huge fan.
He's,
I mean,
I've heard my whole life growing up,
they were like,
he only does pushups.
The only just prison work.
Yeah.
I'm like,
does he does that?
But the meal thing,
I was like,
there's no way.
It doesn't make any sense.
Your body eat it to your muscles would continue to eat them.
So there's no food that's not enough calories.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's just,
it's like one plus one is 89 right.
So what you're saying to me,
what you're saying,
you eat a bowl of soup every day.
Okay.
And you wait to 20 and you fucking do MMA workouts for three hours a day and
you're 47.
Exactly.
What are you talking about?
You said some nonsense.
God,
that's another way.
I mean,
I don't know what he's really eating it.
I don't even know what he really said,
but I've heard people that were very knowledgeable that were professional
fitness people,
instructors and you know,
and,
and personal trainers,
fight trainers and nutritionists.
I've heard every,
I've heard like a conversation like amongst six guys and they were all saying,
there's no fucking way.
No Way.
There's no way.
Even with supplements,
there's no way you just like,
this guy's eating food.
He has to eat foods.
You have,
you know,
I mean,
some guys go vegan.
There's a lot of guys that are vegans.
Yeah,
that's pretty extreme.
Um,
Antonio Mckean,
he's very successful wrestler.
He's really good.
He's been undefeated for like,
I think six,
seven years in a row.
Just fuck it takes guys down out work some.
He's a,
he's a Vegan,
straight Vegan Mac Dansik.
He's another one is how do you get,
I mean,
how do you get your protein?
It's like I could never be one.
I mean,
when he was the best source because keen was his grain licious spelled queen
knowns.
It's spelled like Q,
u,
I o n a or something like that.
It's not,
yeah,
it's really good.
And it's a,
it's a grain that has all the amino acids in it,
but if you have like hemp protein,
you're not going to get all of them.
And if you have like,
you know,
rice protein,
you're not getting it.
All of them.
It's,
you don't get the same stuff that you get out of meat unless you're very
careful.
You gotta be really careful with your protein.
I mean,
is it better to be a vegetarian do thing?
I don't.
So not necessarily,
you know,
it's an interesting story when I'm Travis Barker from blink one 80 whatever the
fuck it is.
What does he to do with tattoos?
Yeah.
You know that guy got in a terrible plane crash with Tj and yeah.
Well when,
when he got fucked up in that plane crash,
that's when he became a meat eater because the skin gap graphs weren't taking
skin graphs where I taking and then once he started eating meat,
they started taking why I think I've been eating hardcore Vegan for like the
last couple of weeks and how many dicks you suck in those times.
But no,
but,
but I've been only doing it like 90% of the time.
Meaning I'm not like,
I still throw in steak and stuff like that here and there,
but so I'm not doing a 100% Vegan,
but I have noticed since I've been eating it,
I just feel way better and like,
well,
you need to clean your dog and cheese by the way.
So are you using to clean your diet up?
You know that.
So I've always been,
I've always been eating healthy for weight watchers because I've been doing
weight watchers for like four years,
so I'm still,
I'm not eating,
I've been on weight watchers to this this whole time.
But you will fluctuate.
You'll go like back and forth.
What I'm saying is that there's,
you're obviously not watching it all the time and if you do and you all of a
sudden get on a strict thing like like a a Vegan Diet,
when you're getting all these nutrients and all this fiber and all this water
and your system,
you're going to feel way better for sure,
but a lot of it is because I've been eating a shitload of Qinhuangdao.
That's my new favorite thing came off.
Like I said,
it's spelled funky but it's protein or it's what they say is the most complete
plant based protein.
There's a plus.
What swingers that makes the best.
You just go there and get a side of it.
I make protein shakes.
I put hemp protein in it.
Had protein is pretty good the way pros and really is better.
That's what I was doing.
I was doing 150 grams of the whey protein is probably strangely enough.
I had developed a kidney stone shortly after that.
Ran The water shot.
Next time you gotta drink water,
Sun Porch,
drinking a lot more now.
Very important.
Even better than water.
You ever have coconut water?
Oh shit son.
Oh,
you got to coconut water it up man.
It's the best.
Coco would no water.
It's called o two C.
It's called C o.
C o two c two o c two.
Oh,
that's fucking awesome.
Wait way better than that coconut one or whatever it's called
because it just crashed this coconut waters,
the fucking bomb diggity folks.
And it's super healthy for you.
Coconut water,
if you,
uh,
if you look at it's like nutritional profile,
it's way better for you then.
Um,
sports drinks.
No,
it's like the best for you.
Like right after you get done working out.
Sweet.
It's delicious too.
It is good.
So you've got to take care of your body,
son.
It's all we're talking about here.
Fitness and shit.
I just started,
you know,
I'm 30.
I have to say this one more time because I get people complain when someone
goes,
Oh,
I'm a vegetarian.
I go,
how many dicks are so I'm not serious.
Okay.
Fucking relaxed with the tweets.
You ignorant.
Asshole.
Vegetarianism is not equal gate.
If you're dealing with animal suffering and cruelty.
It's just a joke,
man.
You think Mr. Rogers was,
cause I watched it the other day and I felt like I was watching like myself
getting raped or something like that was like,
oh,
this creepy guy.
Oh my God,
he's so gay now.
There's a lot of girls like that.
Or like Mr Wizzard that couldn't be around to me.
Like old guy I pyramid and the base to Rogers was probably one of those guys
that was gay.
Oh.
But he never did anything and do anything because he didn't want to ruin his
reputation.
He was very kept.
He probably and cried.
He probably had three secrets,
you know,
that haunted him everyday.
Tracy Rogers is a,
is a pillar in the woods.
It's something probably happened him in that,
but whatever that drawing,
the artist's guy used to go on canoe trips with kids.
Bob Ross
[inaudible] dealing with the kid and this weekend,
are you battling impressionists?
I like,
you know who I love if you'll Howser,
you know,
in an La guy for the rest of the country.
He says local guy and he's kind of,
he's,
he's kind of a country bumpkin,
but he's just as nice in his pleased with everything and you take them anywhere.
It's like,
wow,
what's that?
They'll be like,
it's a water fountain.
You know,
it's not even on the floor.
Let's go.
Oh Wow.
What does it do?
But he's on PBS.
It's one of these shows you get so addicted to watching.
It's such bad programming.
You begin to love it,
really love it.
And you just see this guy,
he goes all around California,
kind of annoying people,
but he's likable.
You know what I mean?
And I saw him one time,
I lived in La Hollywood for 10 years and I was like starstruck.
I was like not,
there's a star you'll houser cause you feel like you're the only one on earth
watching his show.
Well other people watch it too and it becomes entertaining.
What,
what is [inaudible] and it's terrible.
Right?
Becomes so terrible because it's awesome.
Yeah,
exactly.
Then because weird,
it's like watching a really bad news cast or something.
He don't know that it's the problem with like the guys that are like,
they're doing unintentional comedy.
I don't know.
They don't know.
Brilliant.
So when you talk to them,
that's when you get,
you get bummed out,
start talking to him and cause you're goofing on him.
But they don't,
they don't want to be goofed on a meeting with Oliver Stone.
Oh Wow.
It sure is Nate.
Some dudes don't.
They don't want to be that guy.
Yeah.
Who else is like that?
Like some people and some people embrace it though.
You know,
like you take like a hassle hopper or somebody William Shatner.
That's the coolest guy ever.
You know what I mean?
It's like I'm a Douche bag.
Yes,
but I'm a good one.
You know?
It's just got that.
It's got that.
I know I'm a douche feeling.
I don't think know.
We're used to just go so much.
So many people tugging on them.
You have to act a certain way.
He's,
he's,
you have to be able to distance yourself slightly from people.
Braces,
the caricature he is,
you know what I mean?
There's a little of that,
but he's also,
you know,
he's a fucking talented guys who've been around a long Goddamn to shipped.
It will be fuck with them all day.
I don't know anything about price.
Yeah,
exactly.
He was killer on,
that's why he's on the greatest twilight zone episode.
Ever nightmare at 20,000 feet.
How crazy is my man Charlie sheet?
Oh Dude,
I love it.
The story just keeps getting better,
man.
Charlie Sheen,
if you don't know the story,
Charlie Sheen got arrested in a hotel in New York City.
Coked up screaming nigger prostitute was locked in his bathroom porn process.
The porn star who wasn't even black porn stars wasn't even black.
He just brought the word and he,
um,
wanted to,
uh,
to get her to fuck him,
but she wouldn't do anything until she got her money and he couldn't find his
money.
This is a story that radar online was saying.
So,
uh,
he,
he fucking starts punching holes in the wall screaming nigger.
Yeah.
I love that.
When I heard that,
I was like,
it's getting so good now.
It's like,
it's like you can't get any better.
I it really wake you get better as if his bitch had her iPhone out,
please release released the video almost looking at this like guy at like almost
like he's untouchable.
This guy's on about the fuck he's got a race.
There's something going on there.
Cause I don't know if you guys remember like six months ago there was something
to do with like Mexican gangs and those guys and what guys,
the cast of that show,
the two kids,
the two dads and a kid was the kid.
Somebody was trying to,
his ex wife like hired a dude like Omar from the wire or something to go grill
him.
Like there was a no Daugherty from what the other guy from the show.
The other guy from the show that show is straight up gangster.
You go see a filming,
you said straight up and you do your hands.
You're the least gangster man ever exist.
You could do a filming of that.
There's probably some sketchy shit there.
You know,
like there's probably like crazy gang and the worst thing if the show is awful,
I went,
the show is,
oh,
it seems like it show is horrible.
I don't understand if mad men was rid of well shit like that,
I'd be like,
oh,
that'd be pretty cool.
But it's like this shows the worst show ever and it gets the best ratings ever.
Like it's the biggest,
it's the highest rated show.
But sitcoms,
there's only,
what is the big deal behind the show?
What is,
what do people like about,
you know,
it's the one liners.
It's the quips.
It's just,
you know,
it's just,
it appeals to families I guess.
I don't know.
I mean it's kind of,
you know,
I've watched it because I asked every gride dates for some reason,
likes that show.
So I have that shit on my DVR.
So once in a while that's one of my go to bed shows.
Very stupid.
But,
but like I put it on before,
like before I go to bed.
And so I ended up like half watching it.
You know,
it's just fucking,
it's a sitcom,
you know,
it's just,
it's,
it's a,
it's a soup.
Watched one part of one episode was like,
all right,
let's see what this is all about.
And I gave it like 15 seconds to fuck my watch.
I mean,
as a comedian,
you're a teacher.
You just can't,
you just can't.
Honestly,
like,
people don't know how hard it is to go from being a comedian to doing shitty
comedy.
Doing shitty comedy is hard.
Doing a Shitty Sit-com Shitty sitcoms are brutality.
They're really hard to do and they're terrible.
You've done sitcoms.
What was your Shogun for you on a shitty one,
man?
Frank TV that was,
no,
it wasn't a shitty one,
wasn't it?
No,
it wasn't a,
a decent,
it was decent scale.
It was small.
I'll say it was small,
so it was like,
you know,
definitely didn't,
it wasn't like showing up to the set of a major
network.
It was TBS,
but I had fun.
It was enjoyable.
But,
but news radio now that's huge.
And then what was that like showing it wasn't huge.
We did that become a huge,
it became huge after while we were on the air.
I mean we got to syndication barely,
but we like,
we were suppose to get a hundred episodes.
We accidentally did 98,
but what happened with news radio is we just kept getting moved.
We got moved nine times over the course of five seasons.
Yeah.
We got moved like crazy.
And you realize that a lot of like what puts a Sitcom and certain places like
Paul Simms used to talk about it.
There was the shit sandwich between friends and uh,
there was something else that was on after friends and was great to something
else.
It was good.
And they would,
they would always sandwich these shitty shows in those spots before that.
And those shows would be huge.
Like,
like,
um,
there was a one called the single guy that was his terrible show,
you know,
really nice guy who was the star Jonathan something or another.
I remember that Super Nice Guy.
But the show was terrible.
It just wasn't good.
But meanwhile was getting giant monster ratings.
Yes.
So people would watch it.
And you know,
sims would pitch and we would get moved around and we were on like Tuesday and
Sunday and Wednesday and Monday we just got to get moved all over the place and
no one,
even when the show got canceled,
it partially was because Phil Hartman got killed.
You know.
And so the last season we did with love it's,
and the season,
the last season would,
for a couple reasons wasn't as good.
It wasn't as good because we had a different executive producer because Paul
Simms was working on this other thing called overseas that I was the star off.
It was another sitcom that they were trying to do on NBC.
And part of it was because Phil was gone and it was a totally different vibe.
Right.
You know,
so we had,
you know,
Jon Lovitz who was very funny,
but it's very different and we had to kind of adjust and everything was all
fucked up.
Cause you know,
just a few months ago,
the dude was hanging out with us and now he's murdered and we have to like do a
whole episode where we have to like,
you know,
talk about how he died.
And then this guy,
the love his character gets introduced.
And so that was part of the reason why I'm getting canceled.
But the other reason was it wasn't that successful.
They would,
they would come in,
we got moved around so many times the writers would come in like this guy,
uh,
Lou Morton who's Hilarious,
very,
very funny,
right in this motherfucker got me addicted to quake.
He was the guy who got me addicted because he was really good at and we battled
back and forth at work cause they had a whole quake lan local area networks set
up there.
He used to come in,
um,
on the day of the ratings were released with whatever number we were.
Cause like it was like,
it became like a joke written on his t shirt and he came in one day and it said
88,
88 or 88th.
And of all the shows on TV where 88 wow.
Especially what in 97 98 they were there.
Even that many shows on TV shows see where we're like,
Whoa,
wow,
eighth or we might've been 84 it was in the eighties I mean the thing is that w
weren't you just glad to show up and be working in Hollywood?
It's definitely,
absolutely,
but I'm saying is it just,
I,
I they would,
people would always bitch people on the site.
It would be like,
this is fucking bullshit.
You know?
Why does,
you know if Caroline in the city get to beyond,
they would call Caroline in the Shitty,
see the new Promo for Carolina Shinny fun shows.
Terrible.
There was a lot of that going on.
There's a lot of that going on on the set,
but there was also a lot of people that were like,
this is,
we're doing something really special.
This is like a lot of fun.
Well,
as a comedian too,
you already have kind of a more of a blue collar work ethic that we have over
actors I think a lot.
Not all,
but for sure appreciated it more because I never expected it,
you know,
and that's different thing.
Actors,
those grow up wanting to be in sitcoms.
Me,
I was on a sitcom like almost per chance.
Oh Wow.
It's a whole thing became,
I never took act.
Is it that you heard this story about that?
That did I hear right that Ray Romano was,
he was the original host.
They fired him and hired a another actor to do it for the pilot so that then the
other actor did it for the pilot and then they fired him and hired me.
So I didn't really take race part.
I took the guy who stole race part.
Isn't that something how stories work out?
Like just that,
that,
that close.
That could have been some other than this,
when they decided to go a different way with it,
they just,
you know,
it wasn't there.
Ray wasn't good.
It was like,
you know,
ray was older and was more relaxed and just try it.
They were trying to figure out the next guy was like the Zany guys and they're
like,
wow,
that didn't work either.
And then I just got lucky.
I just came in last year as you're taking a bunch of acting classes.
No,
I've been on a shitty show though.
I've got a development deal with Fox.
It was with Disney actually.
And then I was calling the show called hardball.
This is how bad the show us.
It was a baseball show.
It was a sick cow and it could have been hilarious cause the guys who originally
wrote it,
this guy's named Jeff Martin and Kevin Curran,
they were writers for the Simpsons and they wrote from married with children
that were brilliant.
They wrote a brilliant pilot.
The pilot was hilarious.
Jim Brewer was in the pilot,
so Algebra and uh,
Mike Star and you might have seen him,
he was in good fellows,
has been a bunch of movies and Bruce Greenwood and it was not a good,
good cast to go like good.
Alexandra went worth.
But the,
the,
the real problem was with the network and with,
uh,
they didn't want these guys,
Jeff and Kevin to be the producers of the show because they didn't think they
knew how to run a show.
So they brought in this other dude.
The other dude just started fucking hacking it up,
uh,
it up,
taking scripts and just butchering them and just terrible jokes.
And he would go and do coke on his yacht with this girl who was playing my
girlfriend in the,
in the,
in this,
uh,
first episode,
he,
uh,
he became friends with his check and we'd take her on his yacht and they would
write and he would do blown fucker and back with the worst crawl time.
But when they would come back,
like she would have like more reliance on God.
And finally it got to,
we filmed a few episodes with this guy and he was so hated and it was so the,
the,
the tension on the set was so bad that they decided to fire him.
They got him and they brought in another guy and the other guy closed it out.
And it was,
but it was only eight episodes,
only seven.
I'm aired and it was death.
It was,
and I was done with that.
I was like,
fuck acting.
This is terrible acting.
This is the shit you have to deal with.
I was ready to go back to New York,
but I fucked up and got a whole year lease on this apartment.
I couldn't afford.
I was ready to go back.
I was like,
this is,
I'm done.
I'm a comedian,
man.
That turned off by it.
I was totally ready to go and then all of a sudden,
boom,
I auditioned for news radio and I'm on it.
I mean,
literally like a month later,
I'm on this show and it's,
I'm fucking
working with Phil Hartman.
So I go from never taking an acting class,
never even thinking about doing,
acting,
doing stand up at fucking Jimmy's comedy alley and Queens.
And then a week later,
you know,
I'm in Hollywood and two months later I'm sitting across the table,
read from Phil Hartman going,
what the fuck is going on here?
That's of course should it was business.
I was be beyond bizarre.
Yeah,
that's cool.
You've lived like a multiple lives.
It seems like you're accomplished in multiple arenas where it's like a,
you did this,
done with that,
do this,
done with that.
It's like,
I think that's the thing about life.
You have to keep trying new shit.
Like there's so many things,
like a lot of times I'll say I want to get into this,
but it like,
like,
like my life's over.
I'm 31 it'd be like,
why not?
Why not?
You get to do anything.
You Know How many times I've contemplate playing professional pool,
I stop and think about how much money would it have to squirrel away for a year
to join the pro tour.
Right.
And,
and,
and try to practice eight,
10 hours a day and try to make a run at playing pool and just play,
cause I just want to play tonight.
Do you know you got it in you because that's a thing.
It's like you get that feeling.
It's like when you come and you do something like this,
like in Hollywood or accomplished yourself in a sport,
you know,
when you become the elite of your company,
it's like you want to do it again.
You want to find some different things.
It's like guys who become scratch golfers like I think Justin Timberlake or
somebody almost like a scratch golfer at this point.
Like he's,
he's really good.
I'm like obsessed with it.
I'm like,
he kinda should be.
You know what I mean?
A mother fucker.
Yeah.
It's Musashi's quote.
Once you understand the way broadly,
you can see it in all things.
That's more one of my favorite quotes and it's all about a pal.
Recognizing what it takes to really master something really takes to get in tune
with what is great about something.
The Buddhist says,
if you want to know how good you're doing it something,
look back every 10 years.
That's another one.
That's one.
I love that because that takes 10 years to see your progress,
which he always been step looking back into your progress and just keep thinking
it right now.
God Damn Tricky Buddhist,
God dammit it was Johnny Appleseed seed real or is that just a fictional
character is real and the story is bullshit.
What is the story?
The story is that he sprinkled seeds basically all throughout the what?
What was it?
The western state from across the,
the,
the neue when the Louisiana purchase happened,
I think he went just go sprinkling seeds like all men are next.
They said something,
they said,
I saw a thing about seeds and they're like,
apples don't grow that way.
Certain seeds or don't go in certain regions,
the first one dies,
you know,
and it's like there's a real maintenance.
You don't just spring an apple tree is a,
is a very,
is a hard fucking thing.
It's almost like a baby being born.
A lot of shit has to go right.
You know what I mean?
Apple trees are hard to pull off and they said that him just going around doing
that all it would create,
it's like sour grape size apples.
Like it just doesn't work that way.
You've got to cultivate you gotta you gotta know what you're doing.
So do you think he spent time to actually plan to properly or you just didn't
really do it and he was just trying to get attention?
I think he set up the one actual little farm for himself.
But like I said,
the second generation don't give off as good as the first and you have to stick
around and maintain that.
They act like he's just sprinkled it along the countryside wearing a pot on his
head.
Maybe it was just his song to promote his apple farm that he did like.
I think he's,
I think it's the legend is up there with like Paul Bunyan pretty much watch,
watch,
watch.
Shelly Appleseed has great,
great grand out her mother fucker.
Do you think,
do you think that you would just get used to live in like people live back in
those days?
I mean,
does it,
do people just get used to it or do you think it was like life sock back then?
Did they know where they,
their
life is too fucking hard.
Thanks.
So I think what those,
those pioneers and the people who came out to settle the west,
I mean it's like big balls,
you know,
I give them big credit for that because it's like they came down to s you know
the soil and like North Dakota,
like you can't get through that shit.
Good luck farming with horses and they were saying like the number of people
coming out were just dying in droves,
but the ones that they finally tackled it and got it going,
you know,
those are the ones who who obviously survived and later thrive,
but I wouldn't want to try that shit.
Crazy life.
There was a,
there was a thing they did on a national geographic is something as a reality
show,
but it was like,
it was basically a survivor but no prize to be won.
They just throw you out here,
you got to survive in Alaska.
So I'm watched that.
I watched the whole thing.
It was fucking great dude.
It really taught,
it talks about like dudes were getting hungry like in the first six hours,
like didn't do this shit.
And then when like even I'm real big like this cop dude,
like he couldn't hack it after awhile,
but ladies were able to hack it.
It was just they were killing squirrels with their bare hands to eat and they
quickly adapted to that.
When you say like after the first week all s civility goes out the window.
No more table manners or watched one of the first episodes only,
but they couldn't find anything to kill.
They killed a squirrel and it fell in a hole,
shot it and it fell in a hole and he couldn't get,
I couldn't get to and they were just,
there was nothing delirious.
Like you have to start to training your body in this sick way to to just take
one morsel of something and,
and maximize your shit.
They'd get a kill finally and they'd make a stew because stu will go further and
you can transport a stew because that's the thing too.
You've got to bring your food with you.
You know,
if you kill something and they eat a fucking eight a porcupine.
Yeah.
It was the most disgusting looking thing when they feel dressed,
this thing,
things spilled out of there.
I'd never seen in my life,
porcupine.
I don't remember.
It was something about Alaska.
Just something as I think I've got it saved him.
Yeah,
it was good.
I watched the whole thing.
It was pretty damn good.
And in the end they were in Macy's looking.
They looked horrible.
Yeah.
There's a guy we've talked about on the show that you ever go to that website,
vbs.tv.
There's a the vice guide to travel as a whole series of they do online.
It's great.
Great stuff.
And one of them,
they went to this guy,
I think his name is Huynh Mo.
It's,
you've got to,
it's a strange name,
but this guy lives in like North Eastern Alaska.
He lives in like this area where you're like only a few people that permission
to still live up there.
And he lives in this one room cabin.
Oh.
And he's been up there for 30 years.
This guy literally never saw the towers fall,
you know,
and he can speak good English.
He's a very intelligent guy and he lives his life just hunting and gathering,
just following Caribou around,
shooting him.
He has a couple of cabins that he walks too.
He has no car.
He does everything on foot.
He gets supplies
dropped,
he gets like bullets and and and,
and I guess he must get some vegetables.
I don't know what happens there.
I don't know if he gets canned vegetables,
but he's not eating any vegetables on the show.
What do you always eating is Caribou that he kills and a and fish that he
catches and that's,
that's what he does every day.
Every day following carob around shooting.
But he's a very bright guy and when he's talking he says that,
you know that men got away from the whole hunting
gathering thing.
What is a
firearm?
Firearm?
I don't know what that is.
Oh,
it's a water or water thing raising.
He knows up pipe.
I thought it was a cover of a fuck kind of show.
Is this dude that this is,
that's how ghetto the show is.
My pipes are making crazy.
No,
that's crazy.
I thought,
oh that's the inhouse vacuum cleaner.
It's been fucking up lately.
He has these vacuum cleaners where they'll just blog.
I've heard tale of those before and it was cool to actually see what this house
is the shit.
But that's what it was.
Cool.
This is think,
thank God you got that.
Uh,
that audition that it all worked out for money.
Yeah.
Well,
the reason why I was willing to do something like fear factor was after doing
like a bad sitcom and then entertain the idea of doing another bad sitcom
afternoons radio,
I was like,
I'd rather do something that's not funny at all.
You know?
I'd rather do.
What else can I do to get paid?
I can do this and you'll pay me.
Let's do this.
You can do that too.
I know as a comic,
I don't watch comedy.
I can't stand it and they won't make me laugh.
I don't like drama.
And I'm like,
I like the over,
hang over.
It was hilarious.
Movies are always good.
They don't,
they don't,
they don't screw you over.
They're not trying to fit in a laugh every minute and 10 seconds.
Right,
right.
They're trying to make a good story.
They can do a good story.
And I liked gala finac it's Ilana.
I think he's,
he's,
have you seen the new one?
Is it good?
I heard Brody's to Damon it,
bro.
You so great.
The protein.
Brent is easy,
so it said it was really good.
Lucky you can't go wrong.
Calvin acas,
he's just funny.
He's going to be like make a real mark like a Bill Murray.
I think I already like that.
The way people love him.
He's already a little bit,
the whole stink though that he would.
Then Bill Murray,
obviously he's a legend.
Absolutely is in when Bill Murray was coming up and he was in that,
that vibe,
you know like when stripes was,
you remember striking?
Absolutely.
When stripes is coming out man,
Bill Murray was there.
Like anything you could say was funny.
Yeah,
it would watch him and Galvin Atkins is like right here.
It's getting there.
I watched it.
I Never Watch standup comedy and I watched it,
but one night I was watching Netflix.
I was like,
I'll check him out at the purple onion.
It was like I was genuinely laughing my ass off.
He's very fun [inaudible] in as a,
as a performer I watched,
you know,
it's,
it's a very precise craft,
that thing that he does and he's really good at it.
You know what I mean?
To the point where I can respect and be like,
oh wow,
because there's a comedian,
it's like a magician.
It's like,
oh,
I know how he did it.
Right.
Well I see that.
That's great.
Good job.
But I was literally laughing.
I was like,
who makes you laugh the most besides mean guys like you Brodie,
obviously your friends.
I still laugh.
Like Brody,
he's probably the biggest on spoken treasure bro.
He probably,
he just gets to of us.
And the thing about Brody's
you have to see him live.
I think you and I talked about that.
You have to see him in person to get the joke because people who just feel them
online or something,
they don't,
there's something missing in the two dimensional world.
You have to see and feel and know the mannerisms and see that this is a
character.
But it,
goddammit,
is this character always,
you know,
being attended to.
It's like,
okay,
hold on,
I'm going to put a stop.
No,
stop talking.
So,
um,
he makes me laugh.
A pill per makes me laugh a lot.
Belper Vars,
lawyers,
I was always writing type of hood.
Has mentioned that,
that he's the best,
one of the best right now.
And you know,
people were starting to say that and it's like you get some knee deep and you
don't even like,
capital was my best friend.
And it's like,
I forget,
he's famous now.
It's like,
it's weird.
It's like we go places and he gets mobbed.
I'm like,
wow.
From the Chelsea handler show.
Yeah.
Big Time that,
that,
that seemed to just put him through the roof and now he's doing great on the
road.
He's happy.
He just got engaged the other day.
Uh,
that should work out well.
Yeah.
And her,
most of the beach,
he got engaged.
Um,
and she got to let them play Xbox and
we'll still play Madden,
I'm sure.
But we'll play online.
But it's like,
uh,
you know,
I,
things make me laugh that sometimes it's not even a person or a comedian.
It's a dog.
Dogs make me my dog.
Right.
I mean,
like with standups,
like,
like do you like Patton Oswald?
I do Louie and off and on,
off and on.
I,
you know,
when he's one of my favorite spam,
the con,
the Comedians of comedy tour,
um,
you know,
I liked it a lot.
I like a um,
cause Guelph,
NAC has,
did some work on that one and then who is it?
Who are the other nerds?
Brian was saying,
yeah,
he's great.
I like Patanol is what I do cause he appeals to comedians.
It's just sometimes you just a little to me I think he's,
I,
he's comfortable,
comfortable with brilliant.
He,
he did this big,
he did this bit that I fucking one of those.
I wish I thought of that because I've often thought about it but I never thought
it was funny about how all those stores like on Melrose and stuff.
Like you're like how did it,
how did these places pay for their rent and was selling candles?
You know,
it's probably like $3,000 and it is a whole bid on that and fucking brilliant.
I think he said that was one that you just made up that night.
You see the kid and he's a writer,
a good writer.
You see the kid who ripped him off and was doing his job,
so that was hilarious.
It was like,
look,
you're not,
kids had ripped him off.
One kid ripped him off during a commencement speech or some sort of a graduation
speech.
Right.
Can you do that?
He fucked up and it was one that's online,
man.
It's like a fucking like especially now.
See that's what the Internet is doing.
It's eradicating liars.
It's getting rid of liars or at least there's a major reference point here.
It's like,
you know,
cause remember like when you were a kid,
you know there'd be kid and your fifth grade,
my dad please for the Raiders.
It's like,
I'm pretty sure he doesn't,
but I can't really prove that wrong.
But it's like now you can prove the person wrong on the spot.
There's some crazy liars out there.
Marijuana.
I remember one time I was at this club in Florida and this guy goes,
yeah,
my boys on the flat mother phoned my boy for chocolate l before beat them back
in [inaudible] 99 you know,
he's like 99 or whatever the fuck the date was,
so I get on the phone,
this guy,
I go,
what's up?
He goes,
yeah,
yeah.
Full chocolate Dell,
chill,
fuck chocolate dough.
What happened?
I stopped him start.
What year was this?
It tells me the Argo that that didn't happen.
I go,
the only people,
Chuck's last two at the time was Jeremy Horn and he had just lost to Randy.
Doesn't only people,
he's lost two.
What he talking about,
man?
No Man.
It like this guy just made something up just to keep the lately crazy story up
about about fighting chocolate down.
It was like totally artificial.
Yes.
Don't you think they'd document something that important?
You know?
Yeah.
It's just like how people come up to you and they're always like saying,
dude,
my friend used to hang out with you.
There's just these stories that people tell people.
They get like,
I was partying with him in Vegas.
What'd you,
you're going back to the room doors.
Hilarious.
I found out what a great jokes.
I found out exactly what the shit tastes like.
The C two o water drink it and think of serial water serial Miro milk after
Gordon Graham's because like that,
that's why it's delicious.
It's healthy for you too.
It's all real pure coconut water at a coconut.
Some good shit.
Where do you get that at all online.
Some dude got it in in La,
but I don't know what store he got it from and he brought it to Jujitsu and he's
handed them out.
They actually sell him at the nutrition stores and I just found out today.
Yeah,
it's like pretty good.
$2 a bottle should be getting a cut from this that we should podcast.
It should get sponsors.
Bullshit.
You got to get them.
You got to get free shit.
Less light and coconut water.
So,
you know,
I just realized talking to you about impressions,
I don't,
I've never practiced any of the impressions that I've done.
I just do them like with Joey Diaz or something like that.
I just know I can do it and I just do it.
Are you that way too?
Like you hear someone talk?
Yeah,
I think it's like you got to get out of your own way.
You just let it filter in and come out.
Come out here.
You know,
cause it's like,
like you'll hear it.
If you try to scrutinize it,
you'll really start to fuck it up.
You know,
I'll,
I'll listen to them on headphones and if I don't hear my voice anymore,
that means I've matched it low.
It means I've matched it.
It looks like the Morgan Freeman and I started working on an eighth grade.
I'm here that way.
I now hold on Joe Rogan.
Let me get to that.
Let's say here there's a fella named Morgan Freeman and I started working on the
impression when I was in the eighth grade.
Yes sir.
I was about 14 years old,
jerked off seven times a day to bad.
It's creepy.
And it took me forever.
What happens?
Creep.
And the way I finally perfected it,
when it was like 22 I saw Ben Affleck on,
on,
on um,
Dave Letterman,
and he was doing a Morgan Freeman impression,
but it was horrible.
But he was doing one thing.
I wasn't doing it right.
It's that thing.
It's all in here.
He was adding that everything else was wrong.
And I married the two and I was talking like Morgan Freeman all day.
I was calling restaurants,
but like,
I'd like to get a table for two planes.
Like,
okay,
Mr. Freeman,
I was testing it out and I was like,
oh my God.
Oh,
amazing.
So when I nailed one,
I've been working on a Tom Hanks for years and I still can't get it.
There's something,
but he's one of those like ice tea,
like Morgan Freeman.
Everybody knows who he is,
but nobody does.
And you know,
and it's somewhere in here.
I found that I can,
I can go back and forth with it,
but it's,
it's,
you'll miss it a little.
Yeah.
I'm game show host d with it right now,
but it's like there's scale.
There's World War II,
Tom Hanks who's very solemn and talks about war II.
But
then there's,
you know,
I'm on Conan O'brien.
Like the shape of your head is wrong.
I can make that noise.
That is,
I think that has a lot to do with impressions.
There's certain impressions that I can do that other people can't do.
I think it's the shape of my face.
There's money,
there's ways you can open your throat.
I mean,
luck until he was 12 book.
Definitely.
You know,
you can move.
Contort your mouth.
Like biggie smalls.
That's totally working on little person one time too.
And I found out how to sound like a Fackler.
Contort your mouth.
Be Rough,
man.
Much love Ralphie.
If you listen,
you know we love you.
He said Cartman on us as the Obama off.
He smokes more weed than any of them.
Oh did you hear the story about him getting caught?
Brilliant.
Pet the dog and my man is bringing weed across the world.
That's correct.
That's risky.
Don't you know anybody there?
You know,
I would much rather try to find a connect.
Then you can find a connect man.
Trust me,
they're growing that shit like crazy out there.
Big Time and it probably goes well.
It's a cash crop son.
Number one cash crop in Hawaiian.
They,
they're trying to eradicate it all the time today.
By the way,
he proposition 19 today.
It all goes down.
How's it looking as you,
when has been tracking me I their discover and post is keeping a latest news is
a way to score.
If it,
if it loses,
it will mark how oppressed we truly are going to pass.
I don't pass.
I think it's going to be like the Gava we all thought that was going to pass.
You know,
and I'm just basing it on,
there hasn't even been advertised and there's not been some big push for it.
It's,
it seems like it's definitely,
you know,
and then there's a lot of people against it.
A lot of the growers obviously cause who benefits during prohibition.
That's the problem.
You know,
growers,
a lot of the medical people are against it.
I don't know man.
I think it's evolution.
I understand their position.
I feel bad for doctors that had been prescribing.
We'd,
if it becomes legal then all of a sudden,
hey,
where's my business not making all my money sticking my neck out there
prescribing weed.
Right.
I gotta go back to giving kids bandaids.
What the fuck man.
You know,
maybe it will lower the cost of health care because they all have to go be
doctors again and there's more doctors.
How does that benefit that doctor just lost a job,
Brian?
This is a logical,
I think,
uh,
you know,
they just need to figure out another way to become a part of the system.
So selling it man,
fucking dispensary.
And you know what's funny on the other side is a cops or you know,
obviously they want it to be illegal so they don't have to deal with this.
I mean,
everybody knows it should be,
it's just political suicide.
It fuck about potheads they know the harmless.
They're worried about meth heads.
Fucking junkies and drunks had two cops worried about the worry about violent
people.
Just take somebody to actually do something and I don't think anybody did.
And nobody's going to commit political suicide this year and,
and,
and come out.
That's what we need with somebody.
Huge.
The president,
somebody to said,
but I understand why they can't.
They just can't.
I don't know what happens when you get an office,
but clearly someone sits you down and adjust your agenda up before he was in
office,
you know,
you're sorry.
Inhaled or you could say it was the point of you doing Obama.
Well,
it's a,
it's time for weed.
I,
uh,
it's like pauses the tween every word I say.
So the stupid people can understand me.
Uh,
no.
Did you?
Oh,
in college sir,
uh,
I did you inhale?
I took bong rips out of a homemade bomb and I blew them.
And to everybody on the floors,
math,
we've got a high supplies at the site.
He talked about it openly and it,
when he was campaigner is something they sit you down.
It's like the men in black thing.
They go something at your agenda,
man.
Because it's,
it is,
it's,
it's a head.
It's a,
it's a figure.
You're not,
you know,
who is pulling the strings then the,
is there a one person,
is there a committee?
Is there hope?
Is there a society?
Is You fucking,
if you just read about the Illuminati and listen to Alex Jones,
you would know who there's gotta be.
There's gotta be one.
It's got to come all it's got to come down.
It's gotta be,
well,
her group,
it's definitely,
well,
it's international bankers,
right?
Yeah.
It's gotta be international because back in even Americans fan and like
Carnegie's and all of them,
they'd get together and be like,
it's our country,
dude.
I'm reading this Max Tie Eeb article that's in
Rollingstone.
Dot.
I'm going to stop that shit.
I'll be right back.
All right.
Hey.
So then it went away.
Go on.
Let's turn this back.
All right.
Uh,
so yeah,
I'm getting hungry.
Too Hungry.
This coconut water is delicious.
You A,
you actually believe in crazy dream stuff.
We have talked about this before where he sat me down and was telling his
theories.
He reads all these books on what kind of dreaming is that called again?
Dreaming Lucid Jr
I think I have a problem with my,
uh,
in house vacuum cleaner unit.
It's screaming.
He's letting me know it's dying.
What were we talking about before I took off because it was interesting.
Um,
smoking or the people who run the country,
who runs the country,
who the fuck do you think runs it?
It's not the voters.
Do you think happens when you get into office?
Do you think they actually Bill Hicks style sit you down and show you a,
an angle of the Kennedy assassination and no one's ever seen before?
If I sit in a room with that,
then what did he say?
A bunch of smokey industrialists.
Questions.
Yeah.
What's my agenda?
Doesn't it seem like they're kind of is though?
It's like,
think about like the skull and bones at,
yeah,
like these real,
real upper echelon kind of societies that you can never belonged to and you're
privy to information that nobody,
cause that's,
that's,
that's the most likely scenario.
Then it's these elite colleges to keep this group of people in power.
Right.
I know what she's talking about.
People that have been in the skull and bones from college,
I mean it was John Kerry.
It was Bush.
It was,
there's been a bunch of different people.
They're grown for this from the get go.
And it's like,
you know,
Obama,
not necessarily net really wasn't,
but was if you were going to Harvard,
it's not out of the question to become president,
but it's a 7% acceptance right there.
Everybody who becomes president always wanted to be perhaps a lutely.
It didn't,
it just to you someday.
It's the ultimate political rockstar.
Even John Kerry was doing,
that's why he went to Vietnam.
I mean,
at least he went,
but that's why he went,
he's like,
I'm going to be president and so I can be a hero and get pictures taken.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
How ruthless is that you're willing to say,
I am a veteran and I fought for my country.
Right.
Claps and cheers.
Yeah.
He didn't need to go.
You know what I mean?
Wow.
Yeah.
He was definitely in college at the time.
His dude's like Bush are like,
oh,
my back hurts.
I think that smart man,
as I've gotten older,
my opinion of bushes has changed over and over.
I have changing,
I used to think that Bush was his fucking monster and this,
this,
this ignorant piece of shit,
you know,
thrust into this,
this scenario to kind of lower our standards and make everybody think that
mediocre is good.
Right.
And you can invent words and it's okay to talk about God.
And then I realized that this is just a dude with a job.
I had the relationship with Dick Cheney.
Yeah.
I don't think number one,
I think he's probably one of the most fun of all presidents you can hang out
with.
You know,
in my,
my opinion of him changed when that,
that guy through his shoes at him in Iraq.
Oh yeah.
That's when I started looking at him when he ducked the shoe and smiled and
conduct the shoe and smiled.
He's like,
yeah,
I'm like,
this ain't no ruthless murderer.
Some fucking dude who's just got a job.
And I never thought that of him in the same thing that bothers me when people
shit on Obama for saying like,
oh,
he reads a teleprompter.
You know how many speeches he gives a day that is the dumbest ass and all he's
got notes and what the fuck he's prepared.
You're upset that he's prepared.
He wants to do a good job.
And it's the same thing when people say that George W.
Bush,
it's dumb.
I can promise you this.
He would bury me in a political debate.
He would no shit.
No,
you wouldn't.
Maybe not about policy.
It's not anything.
Stop it.
I'm smarter than that guy.
Yes,
for sure.
It was something he was brought in to represent the common folk the same way
they enabled the,
uh,
the,
the conservatives to really gain control of this country by embracing the
Christian right.
When the Reagan administration came in line,
that was the first time when they really went out of their way to embrace
religion.
Oh yeah,
go,
go through the Christians.
The the really zealot [inaudible] was no religious guy.
They never did that,
but they were very courtly.
But then I realize like,
shit,
the moonies are doing this.
All these other motherfuckers are doing this to run the,
they're making millions of dollars from these morons.
Let's just tap into this shit and we'll use this.
This is going to be a big part of our platform.
This will separate us from everybody else and make us more righteous.
It's amazing.
It's,
especially with Reagan,
it's like they,
the Conservatives always talk about too,
it's like,
oh,
Hollywood liberals and their actors and all that.
It's like the ones they champion the most are actors.
Ronald Reagan,
you know Fred Thompson.
Then it's like so crazy that you would allow a guy who's an expert at lying and
pretending to be the guy who's supposed to tell you the truth and a divorce.
That's a chick that's a chicken being guarded by wolves.
So that's the most ridiculous thing ever you can do.
Getting the guy who is the best faker ever,
and he's the one who's going to deliver the truth.
What a shot at thing recently at the Republican headquarters here,
and it was amazing to be in there and it's all pictures of Ronald Reagan as far
as the eyes can see,
which is understandable,
but I'm just like,
don't you guys remember Bush 41 and Bush 43 they both were presidents to then no
pictures all they're like,
no,
no.
Brian,
go on youtube and find Ronald Reagan speech where he talks about aliens.
Have you ever been to that,
Ron?
Each that is one of the trippiest speeches of president has ever given to two
people talking about that.
The intergalactic talked about if we quit,
how quickly we would abandon all of our troubles with each other if we were
being attacked by aliens from another planet.
Oh Wow.
I mean he was making a point clearly that,
you know,
we would be United as one conventionally group for sure.
We were.
You think we'd go after each other?
No we would not.
We would not.
If there was,
if there was aliens.
The only problem is if the aliens got to like,
you know,
some Douche bags,
I don't want to mention any names,
some douchebag countries.
I'm like,
listen,
just come with us.
We'll give you fucking flying saucers to sell out these other cons right now.
And then they'd go over and say,
listen,
we've made peace with the aliens,
the aliens are friends.
We just come over here,
we'll show you where they are and boom,
you're in a cage.
They're definitely hostile.
It their common maybe.
Well we,
we are where we're hustled to everything and like we talked about the east coast
and west coast and survival than it is.
And you know,
just the,
the what the massive changes happen in this country.
It's all been because of negative shit and all this massive change.
A lot of it is because of negativity.
He likes something in our lifetime,
it's going to happen.
Like big foot's going to get found like something cool like that.
Some legend is going to get expelled or some legends going to get proven true.
Well,
you know,
there's,
there's the,
the craziest theory about your life is that your life,
really what it actually is,
is as the world gets crazier and as you know,
more chaos ensues and you worry about extinction,
you worry about,
you know,
some sort of a cataclysmic disaster that wipes out the race.
What you're really realizing is that you're dying and that your own world,
this universe that you have created is slowly starting to fall apart at the
seams because your life is starting to end.
And this whole life of history and space,
it's all an illusion and it's all something that's been created by your
imagination as it plays out,
as it becomes more and more ridiculous and catastrophic and,
and,
and as it ends that says your life ends.
Wow,
that's an interesting point to think of it that way.
Just as possible as you are one being and there's a billion other beings and
they're all in this one rock and all in this one galaxy.
And I mean that's,
that's crazy as it sounds in and of itself,
it's all crazy.
It makes sense.
And it makes you just realize sometimes too,
it's just a silly nice,
like sometimes you almost just want to sit down and just laugh at the silly shit
that we do.
Spend a fair,
oh my God,
look at why do I care?
Like I can detach myself from something really quickly through that,
you know?
And that's what kind of like Buddhism is always about.
Like just detaching from it,
not giving a shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like if it doesn't affect you,
like death does not scare me.
It's like,
man,
it's going to come.
Just suffering.
Fucking sucks.
Suffering socks,
being injured,
socks being,
you know,
being in pain socks.
But yeah,
death is like sleep,
right?
Losing someone.
Socks,
socks.
But it's like everybody's biggest fear is death and it's like,
if it ain't going to end,
even if it is your biggest fear and it happens,
then what happens?
I always talk about how one of the trickiest things in this life is that
everyone likes to sleep,
but no one wants to die.
No,
no,
no.
When you're sleeping,
you're looking forward to going away.
You're looking forward to shutting off,
right.
It looking forward to the relief that you get from turning your body off and
recovering.
Right.
That's some pretty crazy shit,
man.
Yeah,
dude,
I,
it's the same kind of effect that the DMT is released during dream state that
that supposedly,
right.
It's all anecdotal evidence,
but that's what they believe happens.
But all I know is I don't give a fuck about,
I love it.
I love going asleep.
Oh,
here we go.
I don't think about the fact that I'm going to disappear for eight hours and you
just kind of trusted the world doesn't fall apart at the seams.
Billowed while I'm unconscious,
be cool to be able to hybrid a dude.
Bears don't really hibernate,
you know,
that semi-conscious full kind of just relaxation.
They just don't do much.
They just kind of like a fuck,
this sucks.
Yeah.
I guess you could still get up and fuck you up.
Cause there are bear attacks and the winter aren't crazy.
Yeah.
You Go,
the real scary thing about the bear attacks in the winter is there a lot.
Most of the time it's bears trying to eat you because they're starving to death.
That's how grizzly man died.
That crazy ass holders was living up in Alaska with doubles bears.
Yeah.
You heard the tape.
Have you seen the bit,
I haven't heard the tape.
The death tape.
There's a death Tapout.
Isn't there a death?
There's not one yet wanted to get it,
but it was when it was,
as the camera was running,
I was only audio and a Werner Herzog.
The director listens to it on camera.
You see him listening to,
that's what they should.
They didn't show that.
They don't actually play it at all.
It was like six minutes long,
man.
They,
they shut that guy on that.
I survived who got basically eaten and mauled by a bear and survived and the
bear was shitting on him peeing on him,
like treating him like his kill.
It was so nasty.
That's so scary.
It is.
How did he get out of that?
There was a threat to Ronald Reagan Shit.
This world where you wanted from the beginning of their species,
we wind it,
Brian.
Suddenly there was a threat to this world from some other species,
from another planet outside in the universe.
We'd forget all the little local differences that we have between our countries,
the United Nations.
Perhaps we need some outside universal threat to make us recognize this common
bound.
I occasionally think how quickly our differences worldwide would vanish if we
were facing an alien threat from outside this world.
Wow.
So true spaces filled with warriors just flying to other countries,
jacking people.
I'd like to think that we galvanize an ante up and I'll get together like in
science.
Do you think so?
Do you think,
well,
I think we would to attack the aliens,
but do you think that any species ever gets to a point where it doesn't fuck
with the weaker species?
It's hard.
Think that a mass collectiveness of,
of,
of a fight or flight.
What would happen?
I think most put fly.
Most people would just go hide and be scared.
No,
no,
no.
What I'm saying is,
do you think that alien life in all,
all galaxies and all whatever,
wherever exists,
wherever it exists,
intelligent life,
do you think it always fucks with whatever's weaker than it?
Does that just help things become strong?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think that's nature,
right?
That's just dominant survival.
Or the candidate have to fuck with us.
They would have to fuck with us.
Now the thing I don't quite understand is why everybody gives them credit for
being so smart if they came here,
you know,
because they can get,
they can get here.
But what if we can get to where they're at?
Um,
well we can't,
we're getting closer.
We're getting closer but more water on the moon.
But,
but yeah,
they found water.
No more water.
Yeah,
a lot more than they thought that they,
there's also the idea that they could use that as like the moon is a refueling
station or something up there.
And they use that like as a launch because it's 260,000 miles out and it doesn't
have the same kind of gravity.
So they could start launching shit from the moon.
But you know,
you have to prove to me that you can survive in deep space for a long period of
time that people are going to willing to take,
be willing to take that chance.
Yeah.
There's like the,
the,
the Mars project and there's another thing that they,
uh,
they've been concentrating on this uh,
this idea of a hundred year spaceship,
a spaceship that can exist,
you know,
has enough fuel to run a hundred years.
Oh yeah.
And survive to colonize galaxy.
That's like a project that's currently in development.
That kind of stuff.
Like you know,
fuck man,
that's some,
that's some deep shit.
Like if they really at a hundred years
that's possible.
But that would suck.
Like being on a hundred year spaceship and then like a couple of years are
there,
they made like the 200 year spaceship and back,
man,
I want to be on the 200 year spaceship so my kids could live longer too.
Or You have a change in thought.
I think you have a hundred years to get somewhere and if you can't get there in
a hundred years,
you're fucked.
But the thing is how do they keep enough food?
How big is this goddamn spaceship?
Are they growing their own food?
Like yeah,
you'd have to do something like to grow your own food and what kind of power
would you be able to use nuclear power to use nuclear power?
How the fuck else could you?
What if everybody got radiation sickness and shit or you just blow the time he
got there?
Were you communicating with Shit and three I'd motherfuckers would six arms and
shit.
Everybody was a mutant from other radiation because they'd never done long term
exposure studies.
They had a trip.
We'd have to take a chance.
I'd sign up for that shit with you.
I always think when people think that maybe this,
if this is the last generation or if the Mayan calendar posture or something
like that,
I feel pretty damn honored to be on the last part of the last generation again,
that could just be the end of your life,
man.
Yeah,
exactly.
I manufactured.
So does that mean that you're a character in my life?
Seems like it.
Through your eyes.
I'm an actor.
Am I in yours?
Well,
maybe we're all both.
Maybe it's both.
Maybe.
Maybe there is no tangibility to life.
Maybe it's [inaudible].
Maybe it exists in both ways.
Maybe you're just a part of my imagination and I'm a part of yours.
Like that'd be crazy if you made up all this,
the earth,
the atmosphere,
you made it all the,
you made it up that it almost exists as a part of your program.
That's what we were talking about earlier.
Lucid dreaming.
Like the ability to wake up during your dreams.
Yon and I can't say I do it often.
It's hard.
I've only done it once or twice by accident.
And because I saw a movie where a guy
had a technique where in real life,
every time we'd walk through a door,
he would Charla the door.
He would knock on the door and go,
am I dreaming?
Yeah,
that's the,
that's the trick that during I did once in a dream that Steven,
Dr Steven Lind purge is the one,
I'd read all these books about it quite by accident one day,
but I started reading it was fascinating because he did it at Stanford and
taught all these kids to do it to the point where they were so good at it.
They were developing skills in their dreams.
They could do it at will.
It's basically like laying down in bed and saying,
here's what I'm going to dream about tonight.
Right?
It's like a meditation practice.
You can end,
you can do it two ways.
You can wake herself up in a dream or you can just enter it straight in and that
takes extreme concentration,
like focus,
focus,
focus.
But um,
you know,
in it,
it's like you start to realize how fascinating your brain is cause you'll
completely reproduce something to a t like you.
Like I fucking made that.
That's my thought.
I'm white.
How many times have you done this?
I've done it probably like five times in my life.
It's hard in.
The problem is it's like if you smoke pot,
you don't get true rem sleep.
Like a lot of people like you know,
you don't seem to,
you don't have potheads don't seem to remember dreams as well.
Some are different.
Maybe it's a different kind of your smoking.
It's that true.
If you inhibit your,
your your brain at all with alcohol,
anything,
you're going to have a harder time.
Dreaming stops me from dreaming.
Google that.
See I don't kill a dreamer but I don't know.
But I,
I know that the Times I've,
the best time that happened they say is in the morning.
Wake yourself up like at six in the morning and go back to sleep like Thomas.
That's when you can get them for the novice.
They say,
and I've only had a few,
but they're amazing.
It's like you manufactured this world.
You can fly this.
The thing that you,
you tend to do,
which I did.
You come around punching people because you can't,
it's just amazing.
But your brain says real as you and I are right now.
And if you just,
there was focus and techniques thing like you can use on youtube and stuff.
They'll see,
they'll show you how to do it.
But what I should explain,
what I was talking about before,
just the knock on the door.
I said,
knock on a door in real life,
when you're walking through your house,
knock on the door and go,
am I dreaming?
Right.
And then obviously you walked through it.
You're not training,
but you feel the knock.
And that's what a dot.
How you know you're not dreaming.
Right?
Well,
I did this for a couple of days and then I was in a dream and I went,
am I dreaming all my God,
I'm dreaming,
right?
My hand just went right through the door,
And I was like,
whoa.
And so then I opened up the door and the door was like the edge of a cliff and
there was like clouds and shit and I just started flying.
Wow,
isn't this a shit?
The dope is fucking,
if you could on tested for like 30 seconds and a cause I was going,
oh shit,
I can't believe I'm drawing a flying.
How am I doing?
I'm w awake.
They,
they say they say that that's what happens the first time is you're so
overwhelmed by it.
You're like shot my love and my pants,
my pants off.
I shot my load.
That's what happened.
I was like,
well really going to have sex.
Oh fuck.
But it's like if you practice it enough,
it's just like meditation.
You can get good at it apparently.
I just forget the practice it cause I just crash half the time.
Well you know you asked me about the isolation tank you got to look into.
I'll talk all day because the isolation tank is lucid dreaming and 10 minutes
guaranteed guaranteed every time you're going to go somewhere.
Oh that's awesome.
And the more you,
the more you relax,
the more you get good at it and the more you get good at it,
the deeper you can go and do your things.
Get,
my dad
always told me about it as a kid.
He did it a lot in the air force.
What do you love about what part of La?
Uh,
have now?
You didn't have say this is a place in Burbank,
it's called soothing solutions.
It's really good.
And uh,
they have these tanks and your rent them by the hour and you get totally worth
it man.
So it's try it,
it's the same temperature as your body so you can't feel your body right.
You don't feel your body,
you just feel the water when you get into it in the water is filled with 800
pounds of salt.
So you float.
Alright.
And then once you relax you,
you're floating in that water and you don't hear anything.
You don't see anything.
You have no sensory input.
There's another place in Venice called the float lab.
That's awesome.
He's the guy who built my,
my latest tank.
He's the,
the state of the art guy.
If you go a full lab.com he's going to call his lab.
Like he's got all of his tanks and the design,
like it's all stainless steel and shit.
His stuff is like real high tech,
like top of the line.
So while it's basically the same amount of money as the other tanks on the
market,
he charges the same amount but there was fucking infinitely superior.
How long can you stay in now?
It's like go in there for hours.
Really?
Howard's,
yeah,
it's just like extreme meditation,
space travel,
Dude.
I was spaceship and the things that I've seen,
the shit that I see on a regular basis in there,
most people don't ever experience it their whole life and I experienced it
several times a week,
which,
which the cool thing is because the body,
if you're not physically there,
it's still a real experience.
You know what I mean?
It's still you still,
your mind is still learning experience.
Yes.
If it were real,
because you're untethered from your body,
so your body and you're,
you don't get any input from your body.
So your mind is free to just explore any ideas and and manifest and visualize
these ideas.
You know your imagination when it's not harness or,
or not like being controlled by the body,
you know,
were being hampered down by the body.
Your imagination like creates a world.
Oh yeah.
You know,
we don't fucking know exactly what thinking and imagination truly is and we've
not tapped his imagination.
The ability to create in your mind,
I mean that,
that seems to me to be some sort of a driving force in the universe.
If you look at what the idea of imagination,
the idea of creation,
it manifests itself in a bunch of different things and manifests itself in art
and it manifests itself in inventions and it manifests and manifest is things
that improve your life and keep people healthy and keep people alive.
Keep people alive longer so they figure things out more so they come up with
better ideas.
These are all products of the imagination.
Everything from science to vitamins.
These are products of someone went,
I think I can get that shit out of there and put it in a pill.
It's the imagination.
That's the mind trying to be curious and figure this shit out.
I mean it's like a driving force of the universe and it's kind of a cut like an
all a ubiquitous horse too.
Cause it's like sometimes inventions are being thought of at the same time.
Yeah,
sure.
Like the Wright brothers,
you know they were working on a thing,
but there was that guy over in England who had his thing he was working on and
they were racing each other.
I mean flight was inevitable.
You knew it was curling.
Perfect example.
Ozu would you saying earlier that cell phones,
if you had them in the past,
people would think of like you were a,
I said that so many times.
Perfect example,
but it's two people looking something.
Both of them are gone.
What was it?
If work is going on here and then they both people come to some sort of a same
conclusion when they figured out radio is the same thing.
There's a bunch of people that figured out the radio.
It was Marconi.
It was,
there's a bunch of different guys that were working on the the same situation
and then every now and then you get a guy like Nikola Tesla.
That's so fucking far out there.
No one thought of any of the shit that he came up with.
And you,
you look at his stuff,
you're like,
well,
what the fuck is this dude on dementia?
What?
They had dementia at the Getty.
I went and looked at his scribblings just like,
he literally like thick,
you know the helicopter,
all that shit.
Like the guy,
the guy was so bloody genius,
brilliant.
Like his sketches were just like,
I cannot believe somebody was thinking this advanced dude.
He wasn't even like the 14 hundreds somebody made a threat about it on the Rogan
board saying,
what was it?
Could you imagine this is the guy said if you lived in a world where everyone
else had down syndrome,
and he was like,
that's what it must have been like to be divinci Baxter in the 14 hundreds
creating helicopters and all these machines bisecting the human body diagramming
it to a t and your neighbors.
Just some retarders like what say you sir?
Yeah,
he's fucking his sheep.
And he probably,
and he's probably one of those guys like I can't believe it's a fucking 14
hundreds.
I can't wait.
I'm not going to be probably a time traveler.
Yeah,
big time dude.
I think there are times,
I think there is going to be time traveling.
Good.
We can do that shit.
There will be but there hasn't been.
There hasn't been.
And then when it does happen it's like I said it's gonna make everything Nolan
boy got to break the whole package.
Did you know they filmed uh,
back to the future?
They filmed like half the movie with Eric Stoltz as the role of Marty and then
Mike,
they just weren't feeling it and he'd had to go bust stop.
And we filmed the whole movie from the start.
There are a month,
Michael J,
Fox,
Michael J for a month then with salts and they just released recently cause they
just came out on DVD.
The DVD set.
I've seen it before cause I remember saying to Eric Stoltz footage and just
like,
it just,
that ain't right.
It's not right.
It's just not good.
Rocky.
Dennis has my back to the future.
Eric Stoltz is probably where it all fell apart for him.
And you know what?
That's a,
that's the thing.
It's like what do you do?
Have to get some kind of wonderful than bit parts here and there.
And fiction was the best pulp fiction.
This is as it was the apex of his career.
Was He in killings?
Zoe?
Yes.
That's one of my favorite movies.
That's a good God.
Nikita too.
There's guys like him like Matt Modine.
Like what happened in those guys?
Like Matt Modine?
Yeah.
Matthew Modine.
Imagine quest.
Yeah,
that guy was off in quest is a great God damn movie.
He's going to wrestle for state.
He's,
he's got the,
the,
the heat suit on that or a band now.
It's a good fucking mood.
That's was a good fucking luck.
Matt Modine and the hot chick.
What the fuck was her name and that movie?
Oh God.
Damn.
That pitch was pretty conscious.
What is her name?
Um,
who is envisioned quest [inaudible] it's not Diane Lane,
was it?
No,
I don't think it was Diane Lane.
Look it up.
You need,
can you,
uh,
I am DB.
It should be a vision quest.
Like they see,
this is the beauty of the Internet.
This is everything Brian cast.
He writes asshole in everything.
Every question.
Every time he does an internet search,
he'll,
he'll add finger butthole just to live at the photos on my is an asshole.
Who is the chick?
I'm still
a Linda Fluorine Tino.
Damn.
Nobody heard of her anymore.
She was hot as fuck dimension.
Remember how pretty she was?
She was [inaudible].
Maybe Kate's the fast times the dues in the bathroom fan.
And she walked in and caught them.
Was Dick in his hand?
She just kind of went away too.
Yeah.
Well she got pregnant.
I think that had some,
she's married to a,
the actor.
I'm
Greg Kinnear,
but the other one was kind of like from China.
Come climb.
I think she's married to Kevin Kline.
Haven't caused the Jonathan Taylor.
Oh,
Kevin Kline.
I thought it,
I'm thinking of a different Kevin Shit.
We're talking goddammit.
Whether if she's still,
she's still,
she kind of looks like a,
she got smushed against a wall on her.
I EMTB see how thick it looks like.
She just got sky hopes.
You damp,
right?
It's still pretty.
It's fun.
It would suck.
Lara Flynn Boyle.
She's 18 pounds.
I saw her at a photo.
She was walking on the beach and she looked like like,
like she was from Kenya.
I saw she was a stick figure.
I saw her maybe a couple of years ago and she just married some guy and she's
like,
this is my new husband and his poor guy.
Just like a regular fell out of Texas,
like a accountant or like has no idea.
Of course.
He's like,
yeah,
I'm in an area,
a movie star.
Sure.
If she's loving and just trying to keep it together.
Oh Man,
I've,
I've seen those before.
There's nothing sadder than a do who's on a ride?
He doesn't understand.
So true.
That's so true.
Regular civilian.
One's a married,
some crazy movie stars and stuff.
Fuck Jack Nicholson.
It'll decent texts that fell to,
oh,
I know.
Good luck with all your fucking country logic.
Stupid.
This shit.
I go to work.
I'll change him.
What has been the weirdest thing about,
about common here and you know,
starting out,
you know,
doing all the,
working for the comedy store and doing all that shit and then eventually winding
up on television and starting to make money.
What's been the weirdest part about it to you?
I think it's the weirdest part is for me it's like the distance put in between,
um,
some of your peers that you started with because there's this idea that comedy's
like freshmen football,
I'd been at it long enough,
I should get my shot,
but it's bull shit.
Some guys just haven't Reza rial,
but that itself that you're not good.
There's resentment among some guys that don't become successful about people who
are,
and it's really something sad too because it's,
it's one of these things where it's like,
you know,
we started off 10 years ago,
a bunch of us together,
me,
he kept Barolo is easy and it worked for some of us and for some it Dennis,
and it doesn't mean that it's owed to you because like I said,
it's like it's really hard.
Even if you're really good.
It's really hard and you're not,
Hollywood doesn't owe anybody any town,
not a damn thing.
And it didn't ask you to come here and it doesn't tell you when to leave,
but you got to know,
you know
there's some people like you'll get it at the comedy store,
like guys be like,
Oh man,
screw this store.
I don't get spots there.
But it's like tell me the other clubs that are giving you spots,
they can never name what you know.
And if they do,
it's some hole in the wall.
But if it's like comedy is the most justified art forum and you know there's
enough,
the audience is right there to tell you whether you're any good.
When I lived in Boston,
it was a shocking when guys would go somewhere and like get sitcoms,
are being movies.
You know what the local headliners would go.
He's a fucking Middle Act,
sky's the Middle Act.
And he's in a movie like to them it's like they didn't get there.
So that was a big attitude amongst Boston guy,
especially after Steven Wright hit,
oh,
it's a great documentary about Boston.
I forget what it's called.
S fucking shit.
Boston comedy.
We look up documentary on big sale for the laughter died.
I don't know what the fuck is his name?
Boston common.
The scene there,
there's a fantastic scene,
but the problem was the all the headliners that were the,
the main part of the movement in like the 70s and the eighties especially the
eighties all the guys who are like literally the most talented comedians in the
country,
they stayed in Boston and they just burnt out.
They did coke and they fucking tardy.
Didn't Y'all owed the IRS a million dollar?
They were fucking savages and they didn't write.
They didn't write a lot of new material,
but back then in those days I would put them up against any comic ever so people
had spent ever heard before.
I probably would put Don Gavin up against any comic I've ever seen ever.
As far as craftsmanship,
skill,
delivery,
timing,
confidence,
passion.
I'm not,
not even passionate,
I should say co just just,
just his charisma on stage.
His ability to just get,
get you to laugh.
Just a perfectly timed joke.
It just was a killer.
They don't like to leave the neighborhood.
Know how they got rich there.
I mean,
when you're making,
you know,
several thousand dollars a week doing comedy in Boston,
well also,
and you've got to go on the road and you're going to make one fourth that people
are going to not come out to see you.
You know you're doing the punch line.
Atlanta don't get,
they don't know who the fuck you are so that it's half full crowds and they
don't care about Boston so they don't want to hear all your Boston jokes,
which are your best jokes.
Right.
You know,
there's a lot of guys that have all this Boston centric material in Boston and
they will rush with it,
rush with it.
But if you go to Virginia,
they don't give a fuck about ball.
You want to talk about Denis leary in that scene?
Like who are all who came out of Anders in the scene.
He kind of got out of seeing pretty quick though.
He got out of a scene with his,
uh,
the MTV shit and then with his first special where he got all the comparisons to
Hex,
surely everybody's going to steal and Hicks material.
I've seen those,
those uh,
the different ones in their entirety.
Yeah,
they're interesting.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
Pretty obvious.
Well obvious.
Yeah.
He was a hack.
If from the beginning it's really sad.
It's like,
you know,
but he's Oh God to just was real,
super ambitious,
just wanted to make it and this is his thing.
He found this thing,
you know,
you created,
crafted this character and then all of a sudden,
you know,
he needed some material to go along with it.
So just kind of copied whatever the other people said that was cool and reworked
it and was very obvious.
I see that happen with some guys especially who had been just for a few short
years and they'll get an opportunity.
I'll see those guys do that for tea,
just to survive.
It's one of the biggest problems with a guy like stealing.
Yeah.
It's Delia and is a few other guys in town,
you know,
where they are.
And there's a few guys that are doing well and they're doing well by doing just
that.
And it's blatantly obvious to young kids coming up.
So instead of like when I started out in Boston,
I mean you were,
you were like ostracized.
If you are a thief,
you're a hack,
you were your point MP.
There was mistakes and sometimes people come up with jokes,
they don't even know that somebody else had said it.
I've seen it before.
It happens all the time itself.
There's mistakes and then there's,
you know,
people forget that they heard the joke before.
There's all sorts of shit that people have parallel thinking that's possible
too.
But there comes a point in time when you watch and do,
it's where you know they've seen someone before and you know,
oh he's just doing this and reworking it and changing it.
Making it this way.
Right.
Cause there's such a specific,
like a,
you know the thing obviously the Carlos thing that to the bill Cosby thing,
it's like that.
So still not common thinking,
my God,
he's a,
he's a sociopath.
There's some dude's got a disc in a,
you hear him on the mark man podcast.
I heard the Lord God and I'm good.
Good for mark for having them back the second time.
As Mark said,
you know,
I don't feel good about that.
I feel like the first thing was gross.
Yeah,
that's why he said because he was embarrassed by how gross sounds.
It wasn't just soft balls.
It was like he was like saying,
well you got there through comedy.
At least you did it through.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
You're a real comedian.
You mean you like comedy?
It's like,
come on,
what is this thing is he has this thing for people who've made it through
comedy,
you know?
He thinks that's the right way.
All these other people have sold out
and you didn't do it the right way,
but it's like,
good luck dude.
Go.
Grossest thing about the the marathon was that he's thought that the video that
Brian and I made,
he said,
I think it should have been handled through the community.
That's what I said.
Yes.
Then we could have been handled so well.
Like how has it ever been handled to the community?
Ever name one time.
They don't give a fuck the key.
That was the whole purpose for the whole thing.
The community didn't give a fuck.
They all knew he was stealing and everyone for comedy central knew he was
stealing.
Everybody that worked on the set on that show.
I knew writers,
they all knew he was stealing.
This was not,
no one was stopping this.
And then Marin says this and then he goes and has him on for fucking three hours
talking about it and tell it should have been handled into the queue with the
community inside the community.
You just talked about it for three hours on a pod.
Broadcasting to the community video was 10 minutes long mark.
Yeah,
exactly.
But he's one of those dudes.
Marin is one of those.
I remember that night and God damn it,
if that didn't really expose them,
if that didn't work.
Oh it worked.
It did work.
It's straight now out straightened out a real problem.
It was amazing to see Marin's comparisons were so ridiculous cause he was like,
you know,
he's talking about parallel thinking or guys sounding like guys,
that's,
yes,
those are obviously,
there's a very real circumstances in happens in amongst comics.
I mean,
I found myself many times my career sounding like other comedians and I admired,
but there's a big different screens and it's ganking people.
Sure.
We're all,
he was doing it blatantly in front of everybody all the time.
I mean it's,
it's crazy.
It's done for him.
And he's a pariah,
right?
Yes.
He is.
What he is,
he is his,
his audience has been reduced to what it should have been in the first place
where people without an Internet connection and people who are so stupid,
they don't care if you're full of shit.
What,
what kind of,
what does he look at it as?
He's doing theaters.
How,
how's it going?
Good.
I'm sure he's making a living.
Right.
You know,
look,
there's plenty of retards out there,
Brenda.
I think we'll get back on TV.
Nascar is huge.
Uh,
and you know,
I mean,
I'm not saying there's anything wrong with fast cars right now.
They're pretty fucking cool.
I would love to even,
wouldn't even mind going to see one lot,
right?
If you're looking in the audience and Nascar,
oh,
there's still,
there's people out there,
man,
and there's a lot of them.
And then Fuck Harry wrong.
He would see those Sarah Pailin book signing line.
Oh yeah.
The looks on them.
The teabag or rally listen to the looks on,
oh,
it's like you hate to lump people in state,
but it's like,
come on,
there's so many of them.
Let's talk about the live in a nerf society.
We live in a society that makes it real easy for these pussies to get by and
they just turn out dumb and simple and they want to be around other dumb simple
people and they want to fight it.
Well,
my grandfather died fighting footage,
man,
shut the fuck up.
I have kids and you just look at the kids.
You're like,
there's no blood clot for progress.
You dumped.
Fuck.
And that's the problem with voting.
The problem with voting is there's at least as many of them as there are people
that are sensible and there's a lot of people that are sensible that are barely
keeping it together.
The stress of modern day society is too much for the fucking mortal body.
People's bodies are not meant for fucking four hours every day and traffic and
bullshit,
fucking stress at work because you have to pretend to be someone that you're not
because you want to keep your job.
So you have to listen to his fucking cunt bag.
Stupid Retard boss.
The only reason he's in there,
cause he married the fucking boss's daughter and Holy Shit,
you're losing your marbles bro,
and you start falling apart at the seams.
Well,
you can vote too.
You can go to and you don't have your,
you don't have your brain in order.
You're not making good decisions.
Your whole life's a God damn mess.
Here's what we got a problem here.
We've got damn liberals want to take my pack fees.
That's not the problem.
We got a bigger problem with the way much of a problem.
We're moving in a direction and no one has analyzed the direction which is
going.
It's just amazing when those people though that they think if you make less than
$200,000 a year,
you're not Republican.
I hate to tell you what,
you're just not,
you're not a real one.
You don't know what you're doing,
don't know what you're doing and you're not servicing a party that's made for
you.
He's an amazing that they've managed to connect like being like good folk and
being like good God,
guns and government,
they've managed to connect all that together with big business.
It doesn't give a fuck about you or the environment.
Like they've managed connect,
connect,
hunting and fishing.
Like Bush would always be hunting and you know,
fucking the famous thing where Dick Cheney shot his friend in the face,
you know,
and Sarah Payne,
Lindsey,
are we shooting all the conservatives,
all the ones who want to let these fucking raping companies just continue these
Monsanto's and fucking Halliburton's continue to fucking just crush across the
world.
These are,
these are the hunters and they get,
they get the people like that.
Like the payer lens and it's,
it's cool.
It's chic now and especially in this election,
to be dumb,
to not know anything.
Ignorance is now celebrated in politics.
Elite is a Ms Poo pooed in shadow.
Oh,
he went to an Ivy League school.
That's a good thing.
When you go to an Ivy League school,
he doesn't understand us.
He doesn't understand us.
Regular folks.
No regular folks should know.
People are started out on my dad's farm.
Yeah.
Whoa,
whoa.
What books have you read?
Right?
Why the fuck are you going to be the leader?
What does exceptional about your philosophy?
What is it?
He said,
we're getting people that are just good talkers.
That's all we require,
which required him to be able to target in public and look like someone who
could be leader.
The president should be the smartest person in the room.
Right,
but is that possible?
I don't think that the whole world needs leaders.
I think that the way we exist right now,
we exist in the same manner that they existed when they was 500 monkey people to
a group and they all had a fight off the,
the,
the coming tribes,
other tribes.
It would come and try to steal their shit.
And they all had to rely on the baddest motherfucker who was the guy who's been
around the longest,
he's ago,
knows how to escape.
He knows the trails,
he knows where the food is in the woods.
He knows the best places to hide.
You know,
I think the president should be Miss America.
Every year we get to look at a hot,
new sexy president.
Kimbrow
happy,
awesome.
Like the president gives speeches and like fucking swimsuits and stuff.
That'd be,
and you know,
it's hard to tell too,
it's like,
think about this,
like Obama,
he's only been in two years and it's like,
you know,
and he didn't make a good point on Jon Stewart show.
He's like,
I didn't guarantee this shit overnight.
Well,
here's the thing,
can it be fixed?
It doesn't.
It seem like it's built on a foundation of unfixable shit.
It seems like the the w our stock market,
this tie Eeb article that I was reading about the stock market when he was
talking about how many companies are betting against BP,
that there's like this gigantic derivatives market where people get to gamble on
whether or not some someone defaults on their loans and gamble whether or not a
company can succeed and repay loans.
And there's like this shadow economy that's based on all that.
It's a mind fuck.
That is what I've always said about this is if they can rip off accountants,
how crazy is this shit?
How crazy is this shit for real?
You and I who know nothing about the economy,
they're ripping off accountants.
That's how deep this fucking web,
they're creating non tangible things to make tangible money and they're getting
away with it somehow or another getting away with it and then instead of like
fixing and putting in a totally new operating system,
they're,
they're just putting up new paths and new parts of the registry and new pathways
and they'll talk about that.
That's,
that's what stifles America's growth in a lot of ways.
Like in Japan and China,
their Internet is just far superior to ours because it really,
cause we use the preexisting structure they have,
they have,
um,
what do they use the,
what's it called?
Fiber optic fiber.
And see we have a preexisting,
a copper and kind of old school wiring.
That's why the cable companies and the Internet have never really gotten in bed
in this country everywhere else that Internet TV's normal really to access the
web from your TV and have it just don't really do that now.
Like it's a 40 inch or,
yeah,
they've got TV,
Internet,
everything from your team and they should have that and that and that,
that technology has been available for 10 fucking years.
They should have been doing this.
I think there's been a lot of resistance.
The cable companies are big time.
Like they run a fucking major made.
You want to talk some serious,
you know,
con artists.
It's a cable company.
Yeah.
Oh for sure.
And then the internet popped up.
We already had a preexisting structure and so China never had one,
so they just built all fucking new one.
It's like,
look at us like they laugh at our Internet.
It's instant,
instant do whenever I do a thread on your message board with like speed tests,
it's like I'm all proud of my,
you know,
through whatever 30 megabyte download connection but then be 30 minutes,
something like that.
Yeah,
and it's just the Uverse and t Uverse cat damp 30 mags.
but then you look at,
you look at other people's and they're like 88 89 I remember when I used to play
quake,
there was dudes,
it would get like four ping,
their ping would be like four.
I'm like,
how was this?
Are you in the room with the server?
How are you getting for it would just on some crazy fat fucking cable pipe.
When cable cable Internet first came around and everybody else had like Isd n Oh
my God,
you would,
you could get online and rape them.
Right.
Were like frozen.
They,
this shit would be like they'd have a 150 ping from like a 56 k modem or an eye
I SDN line and what Ping is the amount of milliseconds it takes between the
actual action and it happened all right.
You would have to lead like if you want to shoot a guy with a real gun,
you'd have to assume that he was going to keep running in the same direction.
You would actually lead him.
So you had aim right in front of him with a real gun and hit.
You'd have to plan in your mind for 150 millisecond.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
You guys were really good.
There was guys that will kill you.
They would fuck you up even with a lag because his day because he knew how to
time the lag and they knew like what weapons were good to like to like you know
deal with the non non specific aiming that you had to employ.
That's pretty damn smart dude.
There was incredible good dudes become you.
You get tuned into it and you become like one of the things about like video
games,
it's like your,
your fast twitch and your movements and everything.
They become in tune with the parameters of the game.
Well they say that that teaches kids skills today that is helping their motors
cause cause I played that grand theft auto but I never sold cars.
I would go play this,
uh,
the,
the free mode where you can just run around the city and wreak havoc and you
start to develop a lifestyle.
I became a sniper or a really good one.
I was Lee Harvey Oswald and I would stop people.
I was really,
really good at it and I would go sit on top of buildings and I would call you on
the cell phone because he had the ear piece and the guy would be like,
hello?
Like say cheese motherfucker.
Boom,
right off I'm from a skyscraper and it's like I started living this life and
just,
I just,
I would get thrills out of it.
I'd get excited.
I'd be proud of myself.
I got really good flying a helicopter.
It's fucking hard to fly a helicopter.
I wouldn't always do.
Everybody get in the helicopter?
I,
yeah,
I him about,
I laughed my ass off and you blow them up and you left.
Oh you just a job.
Yeah,
you'll commit suicide.
But it Larry them cause that work cause they're like well look book or I was
working on something over cause it goes over in Brooklyn.
You take me all the way over here to do this.
You fucking Dick Dude.
That's shit.
Or where you landed on top of like the Statue of Liberty.
Yeah.
It's just so fun.
You go around exploring,
there's no rules and you just run a muck.
But after awhile there is kind of like an understanding.
Like if you see another dude,
like sometimes the doodle just come up with beef,
like doing drive bys on you.
You're like all right,
but that's what to do to walk up and want to hang out.
Those are the guys.
You take her a ride.
I Roll Solo.
I'm Charles Bronson and that fucking feeling,
I ain't hanging out with nobody.
Right.
You get in my car,
I'm going to,
you're going to get got there.
You're done with.
I'm going to embarrass your people.
My Jack People.
I have no friends in liberty city.
Poor Matt.
The door got the comedy store was like,
Hey,
let's meet up man.
Give me your code.
And I was like,
yeah,
all right,
let's go right up.
I was like,
it's just the way it goes and liberty city homie,
dudes get hurt.
Why make friends if I can shoot you suffer?
No repercussions for it.
I'm going love friends in real life.
I'm a,
I'm a lone wolf in that fucking city.
Hilarious.
Grab a car and listen to some tunes.
Go do drive by some people.
Police.
That game is so much fun.
Now do you do this online with a piece doing with Xbox?
Do it online with what?
The ps three and a half fucking hate game controllers that had to get over it.
You need to do play it for a month and you'll get this to it.
Oh,
you only do it.
You only do a computer,
mouse and keyboards better.
Just better period.
I've tried both.
I understand the appeal of a little game control.
It is not as specific graphics better and computer.
I'll just always the graphics by the resolution's better but more importantly
when you're in front of the screen like you,
you're dealing with,
you know like you shouldn't be dealing with if you really want to pay attention
more than 21 inches,
right?
21 inch.
Do you want a small screen?
It's not too big cause otherwise your,
your eyes are not going to be to keep up with everything.
Right about the house and a keyboard is way better.
Yeah.
You can move much more specifically with a mouse and a keyboard.
A mouse is way more accurate as far as aim.
So in fast twitch games like quake and unreal tournament and all those crazy
games,
grand theft auto is not like that.
Can I?
Can I get grand theft auto on computer?
You can but you don't need to do mouse.
That's a game.
They get that grand theft auto is not a fast twitch all bring you in.
Most Games aren't,
aren't moving to joy stick though.
Full range of motion.
Most of them are.
I've gotten so good at that Xbox controller,
the ps three controller that I don't even realize I'm secondary.
If you,
once you've done quake,
once you've experienced this super high adrenaline rush of really high speed,
three d action,
the death,
death matches,
rocket launches.
I'm all about that shit out,
bro.
I'm all but that's,
I don't want to regular.
I want a game where I can walk regular speed,
right?
I want to come work in rocket jump.
Okay?
I want to shoot a rocket at the ground and jump at the same time and go flying
through the air.
That's bad ass.
That's cool.
So many more games when you play it every time you're talking about I get bored
when you play death match on on boring.
I like that Shit on grand theft auto,
that death match cause death match 18 people all around the world,
all games,
all around the world and you just love killing somebody.
I know it's real.
I just know somebody I'm on the other end is on the other guy that I really
experienced it and I got the earpiece and everything and I'd go into rooms.
It'd be a bunch of like,
teenage boys would be like Niggas who's ready to get killed?
Who is this guy?
Nobody would talk shit to me.
It's amazing how a voiceover work.
Nobody would talk shit.
But yeah,
mother fucker had that feel.
They'd be like,
I'm 12 I do voices and shit all the time.
It was fucking this one.
So everybody's allowed to talk.
When you get in a room where everybody can talk,
you can mute yourself.
French,
you'll hear Chinese like,
yeah,
you'll hear little kids that are fighting with their mom and you're giving them
advice,
like throw her vagina the ladder.
Right.
And then you'll hear it.
You'll hear the dismay of somebody when you fuck them up in a death match.
And I was like,
Nasty Shit.
I was a grenade expert.
I would try,
I would hold it and,
but I do a drive by and you and drop it at the last second and take off.
And just fattal's world battlefield where you've just dropped like a grenade,
like you're driving with somebody and then you get out and you put a grenade and
it's so good.
I mean that guy,
I had to stop playing.
I had to stop playing and living my life again.
I was like,
I'm not living my life.
For Robert from the comedy store,
the manager who got addicted to world,
Robert Davies oil,
the Warcraft?
No,
every other one.
Everquest was Robert Davis.
Yeah.
I didn't know he was into that famous Robert Quote.
I say this all the time to people when I'm talking about people who are addicted
to games.
We were in the back of the comedy store back by the bar area and he goes,
it's so weird.
I'm so successful in my online life,
but so unsuccessful in my real life because it's online life in everquest,
he was a pimp.
He was like a source where with magic and shit.
Yeah,
he had like pet dragons in his online life.
There was a documentary about those people,
that world of Warcraft.
Did you see that one?
It was amazing.
Like how,
like what it costs dangerous.
It's like a bad drug habit.
It's like neuro one,
like dudes are having fucking kids starve because they get addicted with these
online role playing games.
I met this hot chick that was like supermodel height and I found out that she
was addicted to,
I gave my 12 hours a day and it just blew my mind and it was like,
okay,
this game might not be too,
I would play,
I would play grand theft auto probably like up to four hours a day.
And I felt like that was even waste.
Cool though to put these headphones on and not in the click and enter into a
world.
There's a bunch of other people online and it's a gigantic,
massive arena so you can wander around all these different areas.
One that just came out,
Bobby Lee keeps trying to get me to get,
um,
he plays it all the time.
It's a Las Vegas.
Oh No.
Fall out.
Fall out playing.
Right.
So what's your plan?
You're like,
yeah,
fuck yeah.
I played the first one.
[inaudible] three dude.
Fuck that.
If we get far three for $19 play that thing,
you'll fucking love it and go with B because it's the exact same game.
But it's in Vegas.
I look match GTA so much.
I'd never felt the need to play another game.
And then I heard metal Bonners pretty good too.
What is this fallout game like?
It's more like first person shooter mixed with like a role playing,
but it's one of these
games that if he,
cause he likes grand theft auto.
It's just an open sandbox meaning there is tons of different endings.
There's tons of different,
you could either be a good person or a bad guy,
but what's cool,
it's just like going into these towns and it's really realistic and you can
search through people's a mouse and keyboard because everyone,
everyone's used,
everyone's used to the is accurate.
Yeah.
But only a certain amount of games like quake does it mean you need to be to
actually they've actually had um,
game offs where they're taking people with PC versions of the game and play them
against people that you have for quick,
not as quick.
There's only certain mount of games that need to be that accurate.
Meaning like if you are all playing a battlefield with a controller,
you,
there's people that are awesome at that,
but I'm telling you is that you're missing one of the most satisfying parts of
the game.
His sticks and notice quick,
I've never pulled the statistics and numbers I'm talking about the most
satisfying part of these third person shooters is having nasty aim is being able
to blast dude,
but they make games so that which came with the controller in mind.
So you ha you can't have nasty aim playing any of these games,
but you want to go to the game is playing with a mouse and a keyboard when
they've played against each other.
The mouse,
the keyboard.
People always when I have to say because it's more accurate,
I understand that it's accurate enough,
but you think it's accurate enough.
But if you were playing against a guy with a mouse and keyboard,
it's not that you're never playing with a guy with a mouse and a keyboard.
You're playing other people with controllers.
Why would you do that if you know a mouse and keyboards more accurate cause you
get hold.
I'm listen man.
The whole thing is accuracy and those games the whole time and quake.
The whole thing is strategy,
planning out your map and then being able to accurately pick a guy up.
They designed the game with the controller and accurate at the controllers.
Limitations in mind.
So what you might be playing quake where you are so much satisfying.
You're repeating yourself but I'm saying is it doesn't matter to me because I'll
always know that the mouse and a keyboard is more accurate for quake.
No,
anytime it's more accurate.
I know you played them.
Mouse is a more accurate way of aiming.
I bet.
I bet if you get like the best battlefield 1943 guy versus the best 1943
gardener,
a computer,
I bet there's not going to be a huge difference to to where you can go and spam.
There's a difference.
The mouse guys always win.
It's,
it's more accurate.
it's,
this is not like this.
Not like a an opinion.
This is what it's like.
It's more like you're,
you're shifting,
you're shutting off all games on the council because you don't like the
controller where a game,
why don't want to get addicted to games period.
Nothing to do with it.
But to me,
if I'm going to play video games,
I'm going to play the most thrilling ones and the most thrilling ones to me are
first person shooters,
death match style for quake,
counterstrike,
Shit like that.
You're running around shooting the mouse and keyboards.
The only way to go with those tests,
that's exactly what the death match and grand theft auto and you have all of the
New York City is your playground and everyone death match.
But I could be totally down with that though,
but I would want to be able to get people with like a mouse and keyboard.
You could snipe people and Shit and perfect Snyder.
I am a,
now he's up to,
that's what I'm saying.
They're not looking at a level 10 dude,
you're playing quake.
You don't get opportunities do,
don't sit around and just wait to be shot in the head.
Right.
Everybody's constantly moving.
So yeah,
you have to be very active.
These guys move all the time.
You go to the airport and have the death match.
Dude,
I go find a nest somewhere and I just let them run and I'll let them,
I'll eat them.
We call it and quick they call it camping like rocket jump up too was like
certain crazy trick moves he can do.
And one of them was this dude figured out how to double rocket jump right to the
top of this tower.
He would throw a grenade down and then he would rocket jump on the grenade.
Oh that's so he would make sure that the,
the grenade,
he timed the grenade clink,
clink,
clink and then he would rocket jump.
But it went off to lunch.
We'll go sailing to the top of this tower was a trick move.
And then he would just jack people and when the map,
because you couldn't get them out of there and he would just pick you off of the
rail or go get this today quick.
I'll fuck you could have got it yesterday.
It's one,
two,
three,
four.
There's all been out to kill zone to have you played.
Why do you want,
why do you say you don't want quick?
I want quick.
I love it because kills don't do as a million times better.
There's so many games to you but it's having played everything I like.
I love warfare.
I just love warfare.
If you have where you can use one on one.
Yes.
The one on one death matches with quake or the most fucking thrilling check and
everything online.
I I it's whittled down to one dude online and some before and if it gets real
exciting you have different tastes than me,
you know,
it's just,
no,
I'm just saying my taste.
I'm just saying that they've taken that game and I've made it a million times
better.
So you're saying you're saying to you killed sounds pretty good.
That's a ton of games.
Mouse and keyboard and it's not that you can accurately accuracy.
You can,
you can get these for Mac is that most of these games are for Mac also a lot of
the call of duty.
It has a matte caught up Max.
Alright.
Ea has been pushing it out a little bit better.
What's a good one?
I can get them all.
Have they all have bootcamps?
I don't have,
can I get quake for Mac?
Is it getting to a point now though,
where most games are just going console for the most part?
I mean they still release him here and there,
but it's not,
it's they're selling a million times more on constantly.
Those are becoming just because you can have the best computer and then you get
that game and it's awesome.
Next year you're going to have to do something about your computer if you want
to do as good as a console.
So the console would,
they've done is they just kind of standardized everything and this is what you
get and Bam,
you just set it up.
It should be updatable though.
Like sounds,
I mean are the your computer,
if you're constantly updating a computer,
that's the problem and then you get a virus or you get something that slows down
your computer and you're fucked.
Console's,
you know,
everything's designed for the console like a Mac is,
all the programs are designed for Max.
So it definitely,
it doesn't ever really get slower.
Your ps three is going to be as fast as the first day you get his last day he
sees her,
the quake on the way home.
If you already got me into,
I love going.
So addictive.
Dude.
Are you good at aiming with a mouse and a keyboard?
No,
but I can get good at it.
I would go online,
man,
and I would play against dudes for professionals like every now and then due to
a real professional players of being in these rooms and you go one on one death
match against these guys and just get raped.
What kind of control and domination?
So I'm like,
I'm over you.
I always love Oak.
Exciting.
Your fucking heart is beating a million miles a minute.
Chasing after you see lightning going right by your head.
Barely miss a you
did.
I love it.
I love urban warfare to especially,
that's the cool thing about grand theft auto.
They have the,
you know,
you can go to different boroughs in New York and stuff.
And actually if you,
you can get quick live for free,
just [inaudible] dot com and you can play for free live.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a web based program is works for Mac two and each fuck,
keep me away from it.
So scary man.
Wake,
live and Alon and I'm gaming.
He's your God damn life Bro.
They're going to get you
the chain gun.
Oh I love it.
I love it.
I love,
I was so nasty and death match and the other one,
it's like I would come up just to piss somebody off.
I'd stab them to death.
They'd have a gut check of the death.
Brian and I first met,
we played online once and uh,
this was like in the height of my quake addiction.
And we only played once just because I just,
yeah,
he like slammed three he went to,
he won like a hundred,
two times in a row or something like that.
Cause like I didn't even win.
But to me to see that.
To me that wasn't even like a fun experience.
I don't,
well that was because it was unmatched,
pleasant,
quick plane.
Unreal is,
I played the quakes all my life,
but to me the idea of just run,
run,
kill,
die,
run,
kill,
die,
rent.
That's not fun to me.
It's like I want a little bit more of an adventure I guess mixed in with my
first person shooter or just,
you know,
not having to start over from scratch every 30 seconds or a minute,
like normally you don't,
you know,
we were just,
it was,
it was not enjoyable because you stay alive.
I matched,
we were poorly most,
the thing is I don't like,
I don't like tasks.
I've never stolen a car and grab them off.
I don't work for any management people down hallways and lightning gun,
someone to death.
I'm all about more.
I bring them here to hate walk at lunch.
You in the face pitch sketchy when you're hitting that bouncy pad,
jumping through the amp.
I want to catch you mid jump with a rail gun and watch you explode us pray of
Red Pixel.
It's wake line.com.
Is that what we're talking about?
So much.
Quake,
live.com get on and play for free.
So much fun.
Yeah,
I mean it consumes your life.
Never played it.
You'll probably like it but I think you're going to be easily like I uh,
no,
no.
I think you're just going to be easily bored with it.
You're going to be more one for like the Vegas Vegas or something.
Why would you say that?
Why would it be easily bored if you like grand theft auto type games?
He likes death match match in grand theft auto.
I never do the tasks.
I've never done any of the test.
Right,
right,
right.
That's what I'm saying.
But you like the open end rural,
you're not dying every three seconds and grand theft auto you're collecting.
You only die every three seconds when you fight
and the death match watch.
If you watch people in a death match equate,
people are dying at least once every minute or so.
You're talking.
Okay.
Once every minute.
Yeah.
But if you're also talking,
are you talking one on one?
Are you talking about,
I'm talking about death mat team deathmatch free for all you know,
from,
if I'm playing a death match in GTA and there's 18 people and that you're dying
about an average a minute and you're good if you're middle of it.
And especially for me,
I'm like you,
I get the sniper row collect my weapons.
I there's like some health she rooms where they only allow like the moderator
only allele rocket.
So you have to just basically
go around shooting by people.
Right?
Yeah.
So those ones,
those ones are cool too.
But I like warfare,
like it collecting my weapons and,
and getting a grenade into tactically leading somebody into which will,
that's the best thing about the death match and quake is that you control a map
and that the weapons will respond every 30 seconds.
And that's great.
You can keep running around snatching up the rock and launches as they respond
when every time you get them you get like,
you know,
extra rockets and this guy can't get shit.
So he's running around with this gay little pistol.
Oh,
there's only a certain amount of bullets and you're fully loaded with all the
armor.
Your timing on the armor,
timing,
all the weapon responds.
You have all your weapons,
all your armor,
and you just raping him.
Every time he responds.
How is it free?
Where are they making money?
Can you pull it?
US?
What's an old game?
Quake has been around for a long time and a quake live is just their way of
giving back to the community and making people excited about the game and making
it so that it's a cross platform thing that they can do where it's web based and
you know,
so they can work on their,
their shit while they develop new games.
They work on their ability to make them for the web.
Do you still play?
Are you still playing?
No,
it's scary to me.
Too scary.
I don't want to lose my life.
Oh,
I've talked about it so many times in the podcast.
I can't talk about it anymore,
but I have a real addiction to games.
I get addicted to things.
Um,
you know what I mean?
We talked about it.
I think how many comics are like us a lot,
right?
It's a part of it.
You have to be,
you have to be a sick fuck to want to go up and make strangers laugh to extract
an involuntary response for them intermittently.
It's,
it's,
it's a fucking weird and messed them not laughing and going through them not
laughing and rebound and try it again.
You should have seen,
I was an Iowa,
that's plenty funny bone last week and the Friday night they just stared at us
staring at us and I was like,
Oh my God,
I'm going to be a long,
we can.
Luckily it was just a different crowd and the rest of the crowds were great.
So much so.
In fact I was very impressed.
I was like,
Oh,
you guys are pretty fucking cool people here.
Like they were very,
this is a lot of cool people all over the country,
all over the Internet.
Kid kids are cool now.
Just a very cool and like there's not,
there was no conservative.
There's some,
you know,
some of the Libertarians which are like,
I feel bad for real libertarians and one that the tea baggers are starting to
extract their message,
which are nothing about real.
Libertarians aren't like that at all.
But there's some real libertarians out there and some cool guys that talk
politics and there's some tea baggers in a real libertarians.
Yeah,
there are as the Ron Paul's of the,
of the movement and I feel bad that they get lumped in with the wrong one.
The whole,
you know,
it's,
it's a very,
very tricky thing when you start getting a giant group together.
Cause it's like,
okay,
who's in this group?
Okay,
and what are your beliefs?
But you're calling yourself a tea bag or two,
but you don't like black people.
Okay.
And you think Obama should go back to Africa and you think he was born in
Indonesia and you're,
but you're a tea bag or two,
right?
So it's like,
it gets confusing.
It's like whenever you have a big group,
it's like God damn it.
Do I have to state what it is to be a t bagger?
Must love everyone.
You know indiscriminately,
you must do this.
You must do that.
You must not be a civil war.
Reenactor yeah.
I mean,
Libertarians had,
there's pretty well mapped out though before they knew exactly what they stood
for.
No police states,
no funny though.
That's such a fringe organization and it's thought of as fringe.
I voted libertarian.
Oh,
you fucking idiot.
And that's it.
That's the only way to make change.
If somebody finally does something and says,
fuck this,
fuck voting right or wrong,
or pluck voting,
I'm voting with how I feel because it's like they were saying when Obama was
running thing,
I liked Ron Paul a lot.
I really liked and I was like,
Dad,
I kind of think I want to vote for this guy.
You know?
I won't say whether I did or didn't it,
but it's like I could really,
I was more attuned with everything he was saying without a doubt.
But we've talked about this before,
that they always made him out to be cooks.
Everyone and Fox News made him out to be a cook.
Everyone on CNN.
I mean,
that's not an impartial reporting.
That's,
and even the news and they're doing is they were programming us to think that he
was a joke candidate.
That was the really is sad cause when you listen to that man talk,
he,
he says he makes more sense than anybody.
It's that he's not a politico.
These are not statements or catch phrases.
He's,
he'll tell you honestly and it's like,
wow,
you'll never get an office because nobody will ever have the balls to pull the
trigger on you.
It's a real wake up call.
Whenever there's any political campaigning,
whenever you,
uh,
look at that crazy lady in Arizona.
What is the woman's man,
Bro?
Yeah,
chamber who uh,
she made up some crazy shit about her father dying and World War II would be
wire fraud.
There's a lot there was that.
Now as that Dui,
things popping up and yeah,
she's fucking crazy.
No election made up shit about people losing the headless bodies being found on
the Mexican border and see her phone on her fucking debate.
How she just froze.
She stopped for 10 seconds.
Is that,
who really does that?
I wouldn't stop at gunpoint.
Well,
what it was explained to me was that she was,
she didn't,
wasn't never even elected for that job.
She was given that job.
Well,
when the Paula Tonto laughs,
she was lieutenant governor and she was,
and you know what,
they will elect her today.
You think so that's my old hometown man.
Um,
I,
I love,
I love my people there and I love springtime and Arizona,
but there's some,
some politically backwards.
It's gotten more backwards since I've left.
They was pretty cool in the 90s,
five Simonton was governor,
but we were in a club in Phoenix and Brian sent me hip to a,
one of the major problems in Phoenix.
Do you remember that?
A long time ago.
Many,
many years ago.
Cane Vampires.
Oh yeah.
We were in this club and a,
I had never done coke before.
And Brian goes,
everyone's on coke.
It's like,
well,
what are you talking about?
Everyone?
Everyone hears on coke.
Can I go?
Okay,
okay,
tell me how,
you know they're on coke?
And he goes,
watch.
He goes,
you're gonna look around.
I'm don't look at,
you're going to look around.
Everyone's going to be touching her nose and they're all going to be talking and
they're all going to be very excited and it's going to be like a lot of fist
pumps and a lot of fucking high fives.
Just look around and all of a sudden I looked around and he was like the
opening,
like the opening scene in blade with a bloods tied sprang from the ceiling.
The guys,
he was like,
what the hell man,
that's so true because it's too hot there in the day and they stay in the clubs
all night.
It's just a,
it's a very strange thing and it happened in the old west,
even in Wyatt Earp stay.
There's just always been this strange outlaw rogue mentality there.
Here's a problem with Phoenix.
I Love Phoenix.
I love going back there.
The problem with that places,
it gets too hot,
120 a to eight so hot and people stop
thinking when it gets that high and it really isn't.
It's something where it's like,
you know,
I haven't lived there in 10 11 years and I could never,
I don't know how I lived in it.
I don't know how I did it.
I don't have the extreme heat brings like a lack of days,
sick mentality.
You lackadaisical or you're like,
oh yeah,
you don't want to do anything you like fuck.
Just hopscotch from air conditioner to air conditioning.
Literally what you see,
not good.
I'd rather have,
I'd rather have Chili.
I'd rather that 30 days.
Yeah.
I would rather have 30 degrees like Colorado.
It's like 75 degrees every day.
It gets hot out here in the valley.
It gets hot.
It gets,
it gets,
it's awesome.
In Malibu.
Yeah.
When you look by the or by the ocean.
Santa Monica Marine layer because it's never hot.
It's never cold.
It's always like 70 something degrees.
You can always wear shorts and November if you will.
That's what's good about the marine layer.
It keeps,
it keeps the heat out and keeps the cool end when it needs to and go till a big
rock from the sky hits that bitch and the water comes out thousand miles high
towards the rocks and I'll be up there.
Looting son,
will you be?
Yeah,
I'll be out there.
Looting.
We'd go looting at the first sign of anything going wrong.
Would you put a mask on or do you think you would just fuck it?
Risk those youtube videos?
I think I,
you know,
I would do is just go completely like a lord of the flies.
I could get a crazy haircut,
just do everything.
One eyebrow maybe off,
you know,
whatever style.
Yeah.
Do you ever worry about that?
About the end of the society?
About everything falling apart?
I don't worry about it.
I think about it.
Like I said earlier,
I think it's a,
if I was part of the last generation,
that'd be a kind of a cool thing.
You know?
It would be,
it's like,
Eh,
yeah,
this generation.
What about that last generation?
That's some cool shit that we're all dying and it won't matter because there'll
be no one to tell the story too,
but you know what I exactly,
but there's no,
there's no Kaboom.
There's no we end all at once.
I think the idea is just like,
you know how it's happened before.
It's something real bad will happen and then people will die out and replenish
after a while,
but it'll just be shitty times,
you know?
Like even if nuclear war happens all over the world,
too good right now with refrigerators and cell phones.
We've got it wired and you go to a supermarket,
it's getting fat.
Steak,
pick up some fucking charcoal,
come home light that bitch kickback.
Watch a little of the fucking high def TV,
watch some HD net fights and shit.
How about cold beer?
I think or it's just getting better and better.
Ooh,
it's the greatest time to be alive ever.
It really is.
And every day you can say that.
And so when people say like to like go,
we'll bring kids into this world.
It's like shut up faggot.
Good.
Exactly.
Shut your mouth.
Would you rather bring them in the fucking King Arthur data?
Daya smallpox or stupid coach in fucking Pete and it would sticks.
Enlightened on fire plan is the best time to have people absolute best time.
And speaking of which I'm not,
speaking of which,
where are you a at next?
What are you doing?
Stand up.
Uh,
I'll be in comedy store locally here in La this week.
Then I'm going to be headlining in La Jolla.
What time where your spots?
Because you know the comedy store?
Uh,
I'm usually on at 10:00 PM 10:00 PM 10 45.
There's some times to avoid it.
That motherfucker.
Yeah,
there certainly is.
It's a,
you know,
the from nine o'clock until midnight.
It's,
it's pretty good.
How are you guys getting good crowds down there?
Yeah.
Real good crabs.
We've joined the 21st century thanks to Alpha Lamont.
We're on,
we're on the line now.
It's cool.
It's real cool.
Contacted me on Twitter.
I've gone back and forth with him.
He seems like he's a dedicated to the idea of the store.
The store always needs and need someone to come along the believes in the whole
message of it.
Sure.
And and,
and there really isn't a whole lot to do.
It's,
he's on it.
Yeah.
It's looking at Bethany and then Christmas vacation.
Oh,
it's a house on fire clock.
Tough battle to how many comic conversations do you have with Tommy and
irregular?
Oh Dude.
It's really,
since that's the most ridiculous shit he's ever said to you.
Um,
well,
uh,
my favorite thing about it is there is,
it's not even like people just like said race racist,
not really racist.
He just believe some crazy shit.
Like,
like if somebody does something to be like,
oh that's cause they're German,
I'd be like,
I know it's cause they're Protestant.
It's like,
well how do you even know?
You know,
it's just like he's a very interesting character.
Him and Giannis Zap,
you know,
there's characters up there that you'll never forget it as long as you live.
Shine is a magnet for crazy people.
It really is.
And it's just like,
it's like,
it's like a beacon for them on the sunset strip.
They wouldn't ever try to walk into another business.
No,
that wouldn't walk into the Andaz next door.
They want to try that at the house.
A place they come right to the store.
It's a magnet and they know they can go to the very back and come out without
being hassled.
They can go,
they know probably map provides you a fucking plastic bags popping out of his
clothes.
You see him hanging out there.
He insulates his body with plastic bags cause you gotta walk like 10 miles to
get to the stuff that I saw him like last week.
And I was talking,
he was talking to Tommy and I was like,
I just went to go like,
hey good.
You can't touch them.
You're all freaked out.
He'll start Yiping like a dog.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's nuts.
He played basketball at Ucla.
Yeah,
I heard he was quite brilliant.
Real everybody's this brilliant.
I mean I shouldn't,
he may have some sorts of brilliant dude and he's now he's living like downtown.
And then what?
How Tandra hotel.
He just went nuts.
It's like he schizophrenia got them.
Cause you can tell,
you can have a conversation with them.
I have Brian was just talking about another girl that we know that went nuts.
No,
because that's not,
it's personal.
But I,
you know,
I,
I think it's weird how like if you look at comics and journal,
there's a big part of these comics that uh,
you know,
they do end up losing their minds.
They do end up,
you know,
going through huge things that depression and you know,
getting into hardcore drug.
It's a crazy ride man.
The ride of needing to constantly be up and on that stage and constantly be
pumping it out and turning it on for people.
It's a very delicate balance and you have to balance out your ego with your
imagination,
with your desire to please people with your desire to make yourself look.
I mean,
you have to figure out what the fuck you're doing this for,
why you're doing it.
You have to figure out why bits aren't working and got to figure out why they're
not liking you.
There's a lot of shit going on.
It's a,
it's a lot of stress for a lot of people and some
of them just can't handle it after awhile.
Like did the very need for it in the first place.
Usually it usually signifies something went wrong in their childhood.
Oh,
absolutely.
I what that,
yeah,
I would say that that the,
you know,
Mine Dad didn't play ball with me.
That's why I'm a comedian.
Yeah.
That's exactly why I need the attention of people.
You know,
everybody,
right.
All of us.
And if you ever met anybody that's any good that isn't like that.
Yeah.
Or that had a great upbringing and childhood was great.
And it's one of the reasons why,
you know,
we can identify with each other.
It's one of the reasons why we,
we appreciate each other and respect each other in a way that,
like,
even when I was talking about Mark Marin earlier,
I liked mark.
I don't know how to sharpen with mark,
but if I saw mark in like Germany,
if I was like going to the airport and Germany and all of sudden I ran into
mark,
I'd be like genuinely happy to see him.
Right.
You know,
I'd be like,
well,
somebody of your ill now he's the of my,
he's like one of me.
You know what I mean?
We might be different,
but it's we're,
we're both comics like there might be a thousand of us in the whole country for
real.
I mean if you look at all the comedians in this country,
all the professional communities,
there's 300 million plus people and Mexicans.
Okay,
so who knows how many of that really is 300 million plus people and out of the
may be a thousand of them are professional comedians have that thousand
comedians.
Maybe.
How many are headliners?
Are there 300 or 500 is there even is or even that many?
It is a,
it's a very exclusive group.
It's a nutty number,
man.
500 people were just throwing that out off the top of my head,
but I think it's probably pretty accurate.
You're probably dead right about that because we live in comedy cities.
It's like,
yeah,
you know when people meet a comedian outside of la or something,
it's like meeting an astronaut to them.
They're just,
they don't know what it's about.
Totally.
The comedy community in Indianapolis,
when I was in Indianapolis,
I'll show some dudes are like local comics there.
It's nice to see.
It's nice to know that there's like a little amateur community and they've got
Google it.
Well,
she do around here.
Oh,
there's a bar that does comedy.
A Tuesday night.
There's this place and this guy runs a room,
you know,
they're trying to develop some little comedy community.
I've got to go to Iowa,
has it to,
when I was there,
they had a little community to go and he's like,
you got any advice?
Like go get the fuck out of Iowa.
We had a home,
but it's not bad to start out in a price suck.
It's not bad.
And you know what?
The Midwest,
they have some great clubs,
some funny bones there.
They're always good and I always feel the need to support those clubs too.
I'm coming back and do those clubs.
I tried to do all the cool little clubs like I love going back and doing the
punchline.
Atlanta,
you would do a punchline Atlanta.
Oh,
it's a fucking beautiful club.
Perfect size.
Got Wood paneling,
ancient photographs.
I mean it hasn't changed.
The underground.
Brian went up during a fucking UFC night.
He hadn't done comedy in years.
Okay.
And we were smoking weed and we were drunk.
And uh,
like you want to do some comedy tonight?
It's like,
Oh,
what tonight?
So nitrogen is fucking crowd.
Come on dudes.
She would just get up there and do it.
He goes,
all right,
let me,
let me try to remember my stuff.
He hasn't done comedy like how long have you been doing comedy for?
Years for you nearly did it like 10 times before that bid night.
UFC crowd a punchline.
Atlanta.
But that's how good the punchline is that a mid might fucking crowd on a UFC
night where there was just savages in the audience and he could still go on and
kill.
Oh that's great.
You're so fucking classic club.
Perfect size owners to great.
I like how they have like this little balcony.
The comedy works in Denver.
That's another one.
Yeah.
Fucking epic place.
Epic Little Club.
This weekend I'm doing the Cap City Comedy Club in uh,
in,
in Austin.
Do you ever do that?
Oh,
oh,
that's debit card.
That's clubs ever.
God,
this place is,
in my opinion,
the,
the most exciting place to perform in the whole country.
There's something about Austin and this cap city has been around forever and
there's like so many cool motherfuckers in Austin.
They get excited when cool people,
I love the arts in Austin.
Big Supporters of the arts.
Super appreciate good comedy too because Hicks had like a big base in Austin.
There's a lot of really good local comics and authentic it really smart artists.
They have a seen sixth street and all that.
They definitely have a kickass seen there.
Do you do a cap city?
You ever do that?
No.
Oh
son,
you gotta go.
They gotta uh,
um,
you know,
locally it's like obviously the store.
Are you ever going to come back to this store?
You know,
you're,
you're a man of your word.
I'll say you value one it,
I'll say you're never coming back to Ciro's.
Huh?
Cock suck.
I'd been there before.
Been there,
done that moon on.
Sure.
It would be in a front.
It would be a travesty.
It would be.
I could not do it.
They did everything that does not stand for comedy.
They stood for everything that they should have been fighting against.
They embraced the hackery,
the sh not just that,
the fact that I fucking work for those assholes for free.
My name was on the marquee every weekend I promoted on my myspace page.
You're the only reason I could leave my shirt not inside out.
Like when I worked the booth there,
I was so fucking embarrassed about that lineup.
Like you are the only saving grace and dare I even say Eddie Griffin,
if he's,
if he was in town,
some dark,
dark.
So there was a girl who would eat the Matzah,
no drums and there was,
there was the dingle and the,
there's so many people there that didn't work anywhere else and Mitzi gave him a
a fucking Friday,
Saturday night spots in the prime.
It like people would come up and be like,
do you work here?
Be like,
no,
you know I don't.
We had rented Zz nine.
He said the exact same thing.
Embarrassing.
It's like you're just like,
please job with Joe on put Joanna.
I would lie to like guys like guys would come up and be like,
am I on?
I was like,
no,
you're not all actually Mitzi called.
We've got to put your on now.
You know,
it was just like it,
it was just so bad.
And we would pay.
I look people in the face and tell him what was it like 10 bucks at the time.
But I'd make them come in there and pay and they'd be like,
when does the comedy going to start now I'll give him the credit.
It's young guys.
It's relevant people.
You've got some upcoming guys come comps.
There's AL,
there's,
you know Steve Byrne.
There's a lottery.
There's already,
there's a lot of guys who I would say you're getting a good show and there's
this new crop of guys who,
Bobby Lee and I were talking about this.
They don't quite mind their p's and q's all the time.
They don't the hierarchy
there that you're not even allowed to look at me.
You know what I mean?
Cause it gets,
Bobby gets real bent out of shape about that.
He's like,
the new guy.
I fucking hate that fucking guy.
He fucking looked at me.
I was like,
what?
Like to like have a hierarchy,
you know?
Yeah.
He was serious.
He was pissed.
He's like,
you guys did a lot of fucking talk to me.
I was laughing about it cause this disguise the nicest guy in the world that
he's talking about.
Everybody likes this.
New Comics get like that,
man.
I had a lot of comics when I was coming up that had been around before.
That would give you like advice and like a Saul.
Yeah.
When you get to fucking get two years in the business,
then tell me what you think's funny.
Okay,
kid.
Right,
right.
Well meanwhile dude,
you suck.
How about that?
Yeah.
How about you never going to be funny.
That's the thing too.
I used to hate,
I remember when I started there,
there was these like Frankie pace was still fitter fit or fitter.
Frankie pace face.
He was angry at everybody.
Look at this guy,
he's got a fucking deal.
He's on TV.
What about,
you know,
who's doing that now is Kravitz and he's always around.
I heard he took a long time off and then just started,
got coming back to how many friends coming back and we were always friendly with
each other.
I still am friendly with them,
but he's just a bitter,
bitter guy and that's a real bad thing in comedy.
So worse,
I've noticed,
you know,
I sell them shit on other comics because one,
I'm not watching them and two,
I don't care.
It's like,
the thing is,
it's like the Carlos,
I need to be addressed.
People shit on Dane Cook.
He's never taken anything from me.
It's not a bad person.
He's not taking anything from pain did.
He'd made some unfortunate choices and he's a super ambitious guy and he's a,
you know,
that's what I tell people.
So powerful motivated dude.
It's no,
he is who he is.
It's like people would be like,
like,
I'll meet these guys as young open.
Mike was like,
screw Dane Cook.
I'm like,
I was here 10 years ago when that guy was grinding and I've never met a comedian
who worked at hard.
Do you have to like us county?
No,
I don't like it.
But is he a comedian?
Yeah,
he's a [inaudible].
The difference between him and steal you was so evident.
It was a different slide that was pointed out too because like even like I think
when he was on your show he was like,
look,
I am not him and I not deserve to be put in that he does it.
He does not deserve to be put into that.
No,
not even remotely.
Not even close.
What happened with men steal your two was this crazy thing where he would go on
in front of guys and do their material.
Do you remember when he did that local thing and he went in front of Johnny
Sanchez and he did?
Yeah,
he did like his closing bit before he brought him up and he would do that to
people all the time.
It would just gang shit and do it in front of you and it was like an in your
face.
Look what I just got away with.
It was like some sort of like,
like Badass thing.
Yeah,
it's a very mind fuck thing.
I remember Marin pointed it out.
He said like,
you know,
tell me about your first comedy experience.
I went and bought a book jokes.
He said,
and then I went and told American thing.
That was the most disappointing thing is one of the reasons why.
I mean,
like I said,
I don't hate Marin and he's a good guy.
He's trying to do the right thing with his life,
but he said about this,
men see a thing that me and him on stage was to bullies,
arguing over bullshit.
I'm like,
man,
you know that's not fair because I didn't want this to happen and the only
reason it happened in the first place get more on called me up on stage.
He actually gone on stage,
took the microphone,
called her up on stage,
got on stage,
took it from a guy who was on stage who I brought up and so I was like,
look,
if you want to do this,
I'll do this.
Like,
I'm not scared of you.
Like if you want to call me out in front of a room full of people that I just
performed for and you want to continue this.
Okay,
if you have the microphone,
okay,
you don't deserve to have the,
when you're not even supposed to be on stage,
but if you want to do that and you've just hijacked the show,
I'll go up there and we'll figure out where this goes.
And that's what it was to me.
If it wasn't for Brian and Brian's editing skills,
I mean it would've never even hit the air.
I didn't even know he was in the room.
And you know,
it's crazy is before that even happened,
he knew who I was and hated me because I had earlier made this other Carlos and
see a video that was like not successful at all.
But I had made this video and he,
I remember he walked past me,
stopped right next to me,
looked at me and chicken neck meet and that was something like only bullies did
in like elementary school.
Like when you go up to somebody and he like flinched your face right into their
face.
Like,
Whoa,
you know,
like that,
that was like a week before.
So crazy chest checked me.
I was on the way off the stage before he went on stage and took the microphone
away from this guy.
He stood in front of me and my chest checking,
I can't believe,
and I was like,
are you crazy?
Of course he hasn't.
I was like,
I will.
I will end your life with my bare hands right here.
You know he started drinking.
Did he?
Yeah,
he's serious.
He's like 40 something.
He just started.
Wow.
I thought I heard this on a on Marin's pod because this is the reason why I
can't go back to the store.
They supported that guy.
They then brace that guy.
The worst exam you can still go anytime you want to do.
They set the worst example ever for the art and if there was one club who should
be governing of that?
You know,
it was a personal thing.
It wasn't.
It wasn't Mitsis choice because I had spoken even up there over four and a half,
you were doing that on behalf of all the guys.
He wasn't stealing from you.
You're doing it on behalf of the law.
It wasn't stealing from me because I was so vocal about it.
I knew it was coming.
So the end,
he did steal from me a bunch of times on the road.
I got,
I got calls from guys who opened for him all over the country.
They've got to get calls from guys who went to see him in Houston.
He was doing my bits.
He was,
he was doing everybody shit.
It wasn't just what you saw on the DVDs.
It was every fucking night he performed.
He was dealing people Shaddock that exposed him that night.
I can't believe I was there.
Right.
I mean it had to be done,
but that's what pissed me off about what Marin said.
It was like,
it's two bullies arguing over bullshit.
Like,
look man,
I might be allowed dude and I might be aggressive and I might be,
you know,
overly,
overly aggro.
But I'm not a bully.
Yeah.
You were championing the US,
our costs,
this person,
I'm going to be so nice to you.
If you're a nice guy,
I'm fucking for sure.
Nice back,
but if you're a dickhead to me,
I'm going to be a bigger dick back with that guy.
It wasn't even a matter of a bullying thing.
It was like we have a fucking criminal in our midst and it's being supported by
all the substructure.
It's being supported by all the club managers.
It's being supported by the thing agents who are profiting off this guy running
around stealing people's shit.
It's not like one guy like a Robin Williams who like occasionally he'll blurt
out someone's material or talking about a guy who's just straight ganking
people.
Right.
You know,
it's,
it was a totally different sort of a situation.
If you weren't there all the time like I was and you were,
you wouldn't see how horrible it was.
Yeah.
It was the worst atmosphere for creativity you could ever imagine.
Where everyone was worried and we used to have to light the fucking light up.
When the dude walked into the room,
you lit that light.
How many times do you like that?
Like a lot.
I knew when he was coming,
he was working the fucking cover booth.
Freddy was,
we're going to cover booth and when,
when men see would come in,
guys would need that light flashed for them to know that that guy was in the
room though that material is there and it's so dark.
It's amazing when you can okay that with yourself to still,
it would make comedy really smart.
Amazing that the club's allowed.
It's not amazing that one person crazy.
What's amazing is that these clubs go,
we can make money off this crazy person.
It's fucking not even just the clubs,
but it's like all of us to,
somebody should have said something more about it.
Yeah,
it took users.
It was,
but you know what?
Everyone says it like,
hey,
you did it.
You call them out.
It was a total random moment.
It didn't have to happen.
It wasn't planned out.
It was just he,
he,
what he did is he played on my ego,
you know,
was like he doesn't have the balls get up here.
I don't know if it was suicide by cop.
I don't know what it was.
It might've been because he had to know that this is going to end ugly.
Right?
What are you gonna do?
You're gonna intimidate me.
What are you going to do?
Are you gonna you gotta be wrong?
But he was so confident.
This is how I knew he was crazy.
When I went on stage,
he was so confident,
you know,
what the fuck have I ever stole?
When he was saying that to me,
he was so confident.
I was like,
oh my God,
am I crazy?
Did I make all this?
Sounds good.
I hate her.
Had My,
my whole philosophy and just be had been informed by my own jealousy.
Right?
So then I started naming bits and then as,
as I was naming basic swatch to fall apart,
I just watched his eyes were cracked.
Like glass was shattering in his eyes and like the,
the lens you'll be seeing the sunlight coming in and killing the vampire.
And then he sat down on the stool and then it became ugly and then it became the
audience turned on him.
And then at the end,
the crazy thing was after I got off stage,
it was like a half an hour.
It'd be rating him and you know,
and just exposing what he does and what's wrong with what he does.
And you're not an artist,
you're a fucking Myna bird and you repeat things that other people say and you
do what?
You take credit for their work.
You don't even understand what comedy is.
You don't understand the fucking language because you never learned it because
all he does repeat what other people say.
You're a person speaking in language you don't understand,
literally going crazy.
So this asshole,
so nuts.
He wants to perform after this.
Right?
He went on.
Do you remember that?
I remember they tried to do comedy comedy for like 10 minutes.
It was actually,
I actually have lots of footage of that people were going
and he kept going and then when he walked out,
it was like the end of Friday or something like Deebo just got beat up and
everybody was getting their kicks it to Carla.
Everybody did.
And then when I got the boot man,
he came back around on everybody,
you know,
he pulled me,
he pulled me aside and he's like,
oh wow.
It's like,
what are you want?
You know?
And then me and Steve asked him honestly were like,
then tell us about this,
but tell us about that.
But just like with Marin,
he has,
they should have the calming shores should have the comedy store should his
comedy shore.
Hello Freud.
Yeah,
that's what it's going to be after Mitzi dies.
Paul is going to rename it.
What they should have done is he should have stepped in and even if he wanted to
keep me band because I was filming there and they don't want me filming and
that's fine,
but you've got to make sure you don't have him headlines the next weekend.
Right.
And you don't get on stage and say,
this is my guy,
I'm with Carlos,
which is what he did.
You know what they did was support the worst vampire in the business and let
everybody to feel helpless and let everybody know that even though you are
successful and you do have things going on,
you can still get your life fucked with by somebody who's more successful.
And you could see that there are people that really do try to sabotage your
career.
If you expose someone for being a piece of shit and a thief and someone who's a
direct indirect opposition of what this art form is supposed to be all about,
which is you creating and forming your own shit and bring it out on stage and
people appreciating your work that you have talk after that you were with Gersh
at the time were still friends with uh,
my,
my agent at the time,
I don't want to mention his name because he's a good guy,
fucked up and he got in a bad situation and they made him choose.
The agency made him choose between Carlos and me and they only had me for
standup comedy.
They had him for standup comedy and television and film,
and so they were making more money off him that I was,
and they wanted me to either apologize to him or they're going to have to let me
go.
Did you guys ever talk again?
I ran into him.
We were on a flight once and we sat next to each other.
We were flying to do invincea.
No,
no,
no.
My agents.
Have you ever seen great movies?
I can't.
Nothing to say to him.
He and he knows everything he's going to say to me is not going to be real
anyway.
It's just going to be noise to try to make everything better and that's,
that's not going to happen.
Yeah.
So he's going to just come over and try to grow me like the little Beta monkey
trying to pick my little bugs off the alpha.
Who's going to come over and try and be nice to me and I'm going to go,
come on,
man.
I think while you're still doing this,
I can't talk to you about with your life on Freddy motherfucking Lockhart.
You're a bad dude.
You're a kickass commedia and you're a cool guy and I'm glad we finally got you
on the podcast.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you very much ma'am.
Anytime.
More than welcome to come back man.
You are awesome.
You're a lot of fun.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
Um,
cap city comedy club this weekend,
Thursday,
Friday and Saturday for me and for Joey Diaz and for little Esther.
And if you want to catch Freddy Lockheart,
he will be at the world famous comedy store this weekend,
Friday and Saturday night around 10 o'clock.
You can call,
find out what's up,
find out who the,
the other lineup is,
see if you want to catch yourself some our magical,
see if you want to see some John Kapito Roulo lay it down.
There's a lot of good talent there.
And um,
uh,
that's it.
So we will see you.
Um,
this is the only one we're going to do this week because I've got to go to
Austin,
but I'll be back next Tuesday and we'll see you guys then hopefully with Bobby
[inaudible].
Bobby,
get back to me.
You fucking freak everybody on Twitter,
on Facebook.
Contact Bobby Lee.
Tell that motherfucker to get on the podcast.
He's supposed to be doing it soon and that'll be a lot of fun.
Thank you very much Brian Ryko red band.com for running shit in the background
and making sure the sound is an order and a as always.
Oh,
thanks to the
flashlight for sponsoring this podcast last night.com [inaudible] dot com and if
you go to Joe rogan.net there is a link.
You can click that and enter in the code Rogan and get 50% off pitches.
He kicked your freak,
gone crazy fake actually,
actually,
and then see you next week.
Love you bitches later.